Let's uh let's take a look maybe a little bit. Here's here's
what we're going to do. We're going to look for context. Okay,
we go back to September. All right, September 23rd, 2025. We
get a Dxerto article. Pokemon, Valkyrie, and Cutie Cinderella
afraid to attend TwitchCon due to safety concerns. Twitch stars
Pokémon, Valkyrie, and Cutie Cinderella have revealed that they
have safety concerns when it comes to attending TwitchCon in
October. TwitchCon is Twitch's annual celebration of streamers,
blah blah blah blah blah. Okay, this has created a number of
safety. Oh, the meet and greets between fans and streamers have
regularly been moderated by Twitch itself. However, with many
creators streaming their days at TwitchCon, there are plenty
of chances to bump into them along the way. This has created
a number of safety concerns for streamers with a few like Pokémon
having reservations about attending the 2025 event in San Diego.
It does worry me that it might not be safe and it'd be better
to skip out uh skip out on it, she told viewers. So, this is
from the 2024 TwitchCon where kick people went and were kind
of harassing some of the Twitch streamers and Twitch streamers
didn't like Twitch's response that there wasn't an increase in
security or some plan for stopping that from happening this year.
Uh, yes, Turnup. I think protecting all streamers may be difficult.
Protecting Emirou, somebody with actual stalkers already, right?
That's going to be difficult. Okay. >> Of cancelling and
I feel like they're kind of scared
>> here. Hold on. just of like the tension that happening
online. And of course, we know that if we were to have any sort
of safety issues, they're most they're most likely to occur somewhere
where like people know we're going to be. So, it does worry me
that it might not be safe and maybe >> so I I could see
this. We'll we'll let this play a little bit more. >> I
think it's based Okay, here's the way. Okay, I would just say
that some of these streamers have had issues. Like obviously
we watched Pokey, Emmy, I I believe Pokey, Emmy, was it Valkyrie
and SA were at that amusement park and they got chased around
by a guy. Like I think there's a real concern for some of these
female Twitch streamers that if they're doing IRLs, like they're
basically like Asian idol streamers now, right? like where they
have very very obsessed fans and they're worried that if if their
location is broadcast in any way to people like in real time
and they're there for more than like 30 minutes they're very
concerned about who will show up there at this point. So, I think
that's a big thing and I think probably what they were looking
for is a Twitch plan, a preemptive
proactive plan to keep them safe. the way I view it, especially
with um especially with all the recent news surrounding Charlie
Kirk and of course a lot of political talk happens on Twitter
and also for us people like me, Ray, Cutie, other female streamers.
The people who feel the most negative and most like passionately
hateful towards us also tend to be on Twitter and the streaming
and Twitter community just have a lot of overlap. So sometimes
it it's just scary. And when you see that um kind of negativity,
you're like, do do I want to tell people where I'm going to be
in person? I actually don't know. Don't really like using Twitter
too much because I don't
when I look at >> Okay, Pokey is saying a lot of nothing
there, but it is basically like I don't want to give people a
heads up of an exact place I'm going to be because the most unhinged
people can plan around that and try to do something. Okay, you
got uh Valkyrie making a similar statement here. Let's check
this out. We not have sound. We're in a bit of a conundrum with
TwitchCon. >> I've been so anxious and scared and sad this
whole past week with everything that's been going on. >> Why
the [__] you watching this? Says Overkill 7. The
reason we're watching this is for context on the security situation
and why streamers would be so upset about the security situation
and what happened to Emirou because a lot of them feel as though
they were sounding an alarm. Hey Twitch, hey Twitch,
everything's like we're very scared of going to your event, right?
And after sounding that alarm, Amiru, one of the most prominent,
I believe the highest CCV, the highest concurrent viewer female
streamer from 2024,
is assaulted at TwitchCon 2025. So, they have been sounding the
alarm about how unsafe it is. And then somebody breaks through
the line and assaults Emiru.
This is very concerning for obvious
Can I hit play? Can what? What is happening? Hello. You just
hit play. Okay. It's just the Tik Tok player. >> When you
had a public breakup, how did you go about it? >> We broke
up like every year. >> Oh, wait.
No,
that's This just didn't This just went to a different related
thing. Were we done already with this? >> Jesus Christ.
The Tik Tok players. >> We're in a bit of a conundrum with
>> I've been so anxious and scared and sad this whole past
week with everything that's been going on. >> Listen, it's
not I I have >> It's not you, it's us. >> It's not
you, it's us. We're supposed to do Wine About It Live at TwitchCon.
Love Twitch for supporting our show. I have given them a soft,
hey, we're in a bit of a panic mode right now. >> Will
we ever stop panicking? >> That's the problem. I I don't
think we're being cuz I don't feel the problem is right now,
respectfully, I don't feel irrational about it. I feel very >> I
think it's valid.
>> Yeah. It just takes certainly feeling validated as a
Japanese streamer a few months ago that
>> on her live stream by a stalker when that happened.
>> Yes. There was a Japanese live streamer who's killed
on her live stream by a stalker. And then just a few weeks ago,
there was another Japanese live streamer who had gotten a bunch
of donations from a guy and he went and tracked her down after
one of her Tik Tok lives or something and killed her and stuffed
her in a suitcase. Like like there are a lot of deranged people
out there who will do crazy and I think some of these people
are starting to get to that level of
>> Happened. I almost pulled out of all my obligations.
I was like, I don't think it's for me. And then, you know, I
got kind of talked off the ledge like there's going to be lots
of security or whatever. Horrible things have happened this week
and there was also security and I don't know.
and armor not going to protect you. It's just scary. We will
keep you guys updated, but if we don't, we'll make it up to you.
>> I'll take my top off. >> Me, too. And
Okay. Jesus. I would rather take my top off than have to worry
about this again. Very cool. Very cool. Oh, we're having all
kinds of issues. I see. Dude, Kick is having problems. If you
guys notice the chat have any problems. Do open up the Twitch
stream as well. It's uh it's
All right. I'll throw it in here for anybody who is on web. jdlk_.
All right. Go over to the Twitch stream as well, guys, because
listen, I see the I see the quick the kick stuff oscillating
all over the place. All right. Move to rumble. Not on rumble
currently. Not going to set it up right now for the stream. Anyway,
these are leaning into a lot of the concerns, the safety concerns,
right, that people had about going to TwitchCon. >> I'm
just really
I'm just really uncomfortable with the world right now. Just
so you guys know, Cutie and I are not going to TwitchCon anymore.
We did back out. Um, but we are going to make it up for you guys
because we did have an onstage
whine about it in front of a live audience set. But I think we're
going to do something else where maybe we do our first >> Okay,
this is just them talking about it one more time. So, I just
want to go through that to show this was from September. This
was almost a full Oh, I approved it took um >> like 5 years.
>> That's awesome. >> This is literally from a full
month before this happened. All right. So, there were concerns,
real concerns that people had about the security at TwitchCon.
And unfortunately for Emirou
All right,
do I have the security guard clip? I do have the security guard
clip. Unfortunately for Emirou, all right, she she talked about
this, you know, again, in the leadup to TwitchCon before she
went there. She talked about how she had a security guard. She
had her own private security who she trusted and they were actually
banned from returning to TwitchCon because they had put hands
on a similar person who had tried to assault her, tried to, you
know, approach her and physically touch her at TwitchCon in 2023.
And that person was then subsequently banned. Her private security
guard who put hands on the guy was banned. I wonder if her 2025
security guard will be banned. >> I don't think that's
true. Okay, I maybe I shouldn't talk about this whatever. Who
cares? I I've had a sec I had a security guard two years ago
where there was a guy following me around TwitchCon and he like
asked him to stop multiple times. My guard asked him and the
guy wouldn't stop. So he he grabbed the guy but he didn't like
hurt him. He was just holding the guy until like the con security
came or came and then for some reason they're like, "Yeah, because
your security guard touched him, he's like perma banned from
the venue forever." But he didn't even he didn't even hit him
or anything. He just like held him >> while they waited
for like the police to come. And >> what the? >> And
it was like my favorite security guard. I can't have him at TwitchCon
>> I was just like, "Okay." Like it it was so sad cuz he
like he did like
>> So the guy had held on. So the security guard held on
to the person who was stalking her around. I say looking to assault
her. I assume he was looking to physically come close to her
and touch her and that was probably what made him get held down
was because he wasn't respecting the boundary, the distance they
were they were asking him to, right? Uh yes. So, Porter Beller,
obviously, now I'm I'm going to point this out and people will
get upset, but from the venue's point of view, from Twitch's
point of view, obviously there are issues when you go to fill
a big venue with like insurance and stuff, right? And you're
probably insured from liability from things like your security
having to put hands on somebody because of a an actual threatening
situation, but you may not be insured from private security.
There may be something about private security, you know, random
people doing there that you could be held liable for. If you
allow that, if you allow the streamers to have their private
security, to put hands on people, and then to return, that could
easily be a thing that turns into an insurance situation for
you, right? Like a real problem. So, I I totally understand that
from the venue's point of view. In that case, I think then you
it's incumbent on you to identify a couple of bigger streamers
and to give them extra security that you pay for and can have
under your brand and you can have insured and and be like okay
with being there, right? Like you probably need to double down
on things cuz you can't just go, well listen, you can't your
private security is banned because they touched somebody who
is stalking you. Um so you don't get to be secure now. But I
again I don't get the impression that they prevented private
security from returning right or sorry from going to the event
with these people. What I think happened is private sec her ex
specific private security guard was banned from returning
because
they had put hands on somebody,
right? Which I think could be again a liability issue where if
you don't show that you're you're going to let people or ban
people from the arena if they're doing something, there could
be like a problem, right? She had private security at this event.
The person who pushes who pushes the actual vendor here is Emir's
private security guard.
This is actually Emy's private security guard. So, she wasn't
banned from having private security at the event. This is her
private security guard who pushes this guy. I do wonder if he'll
be banned from the event going forward. Uh probably horrible
optics for Twitch if that's the case. Right. Do we know the reason
they're banned? I don't know the reason they're banned. I don't
know. We could look into that. That could be a thing. She could
be kind of, you know, being hyperbolic about it. It's entirely
possible. Okay. So, she talked about that with Jason the Ween,
how her her the private security guard she trusted was not allowed
to be at this event. Would that have made a difference? Hard
to say. Okay.
Actually, quite difficult to say. The other thing that was interesting
is I believe Emir is contractually obligated to be there. That
she had some contract for one of her shows or something. That
is the reason she was forced to be there. that everybody else
dropped out with the safety concerns. Everyone else didn't want
to go. Listen, these people are going to TwitchCon. I'm sure
they're managing their own stuff, right? They didn't want to
go to the public meet and greet. I believe Emmy was forced to
go. >> So, I had to cancel my meet and greet because of
the stuff. But in order to it's I can't cancel my meet and greet
and not cancel her show because of the fact that the reason I
cancel my meet and greet is I don't want to be in the same place
for 2 hours
>> because of people being weird. >> And then I'm
under contract with them. So I can't cancel one and not cancel
the >> Interesting. A
>> I kept my mean greet cuz I wanted to keep my show. Surely
it'll be fine.
So apparently
apparently if you cancel one you have to cancel the other or
something is what SA is saying. So like there's a there's a show
that that Emiru is doing at TwitchCon that she basically has
to do a meet and greet. SA canceled her meet and greet and therefore
could not go to the show that Emir is producing for TwitchCon.
Right. Emiru says, "Well, I'm gonna keep my meet and greet because
I literally worked on a show, some specific content piece for
TwitchCon, and I'd like that to go on." So, it sucks that not
only are my friends cancelling, but I'd like it to go on and
then she is actually assaulted. Oh, it's a cosplay competition.
Okay. Yeah. So, that's that's rough, right? That she has to go
to this meet and greet. She's forced to, and then this happens.
Uh, big time. Yikes, guys.
Okay. Uh, let's see here. We got I just wanted to make sure we
got all of the context from before this happens
and then I'm going to start going into the emir response.
Okay.
Uh, quick quick addendum for the stream. I want to find out Oh,
sorry. This was the blog post from October 8th, 2025 from 10
days ago about security. I did want to look at this cuz Twitch
heard that people were complaining about the security there and
they actually wanted to reassure everybody. All right. what we're
doing to keep you safe at TwitchCon. We're heading to San Diego
to mark 10 years of TwitchCon and we're excited to celebrate
with you. TwitchCon is where our community comes together in
person to hang out and connect and make the best memories. It's
a celebration of everything we've built together and it's the
place to experience the best of Twitch live.
We put a lot of care into TwitchCon planning each year and a
huge area of investment is event security. In the months leading
up to TwitchCon, we build out systems and processes designed
to ensure your safety and the safety of those around you. We
recognize that to have a good time at TwitchCon and truth truly
enjoy the experience, you have to feel safe. We employ world-class
teams and equipment focused on protecting our attendees. Now,
this is this is cool. Where was the worldass
teams and equipment in terms of the actual assault that happened?
Do you see a single piece of world class team, world class equipment,
anything that that could be?
You've got 110 lb security girl here who's letting people through
the line.
That's the worldass security team that you've got in place here.
Uh you have, by the way, what you don't see in this clip until
Oh, no. It pulls back a little bit. What you don't see is this
clip in this clip is there's no divider between the individual
influencers. Okay? So, this guy cuts across one influencers booth
who probably, you know, they're not quite as concerned about
security for the VTuber meet and greet. Okay, this guy cuts through
the Vtuber meet and greet to get to Emiru,
right? There's no divider. So, world class equipment, worldass
teams, there's literally no divider. There's nothing preventing
this, right? Like this, this was the easiest thing in the world
for this guy to do. So, I again,
it's just a little it's a little goofy. Their statements coming
back to haunt them here, okay? in real time that VTuber could
have been stabbed. I guess so. Uh I heard there was a clip of
somebody claiming that there could have been a knife. I don't
think there was a knife. The guy could have had a knife. He didn't,
right? Or I assume if he if for some reason you think he had
a knife, he definitely wasn't doing anything with Amiru there,
right? I saw people like putting this out there and I'm like,
"No, he he took her pen." Okay, it looks like he took her pen.
All right. Like I I was like, "Dude, there's no way he's taking
a knife. That's [__] That's crazy." Cuz he had his
hands on her. Thank god he didn't have a knife, you know. So,
we put a lot of uh care and planning in worldclass teams and
processes. All right. Our world-class teams and equipment focused
on protecting our attendees. This year, as we do each year, we
re we revisited and bolstered our security approach, building
on a best-in-class foundation. Below is additional information
about how we approach safety at TwitchCon. We've kept things
high level on purpose in order to protect attendees and the integrity
of our safety operations. We can't disclose specific details
Wow.
Imagine he grabbed her and ran away Viking style. Listen, I don't
think he could have done that. No, Tanibum. She did have her
private security there, right? She did have her private security
there and the private security guy pushed the dude away. So,
I think she had taken her safety into her own hands and she was
probably going to be fine eventually. It's just like you would
probably want somebody, you know, standing a little closer, somebody
who could react a little closer or sorry, react a little more
quickly.
Okay, with all that said, with the the initial clips, the initial
context laid down, let's get into the new content for the day.
Emirou's statement on Twitter from this morning. All right, she
made a statement on Twitter before she went live today. Here
it is in full. Let's take a quick look. All right, let's take
a look. Got to keep a safe buffer zone. Dude, Dingolingus, I
think um I I truly believe leaving that opening between the different
influencers that the lines were basically like once you got to
the influencers booth, you could cut between the lines. That's
obviously a massive security hole. I don't know what security
person allowed that to just happen, right?
Yeah, I've got no idea. But anyway, Dan Clansancy lied. Emir
almost died. So true. Sweatpants freedom. Dan Clansancy lied.
Emirou almost died.
Fire Dan Clansancy now. It'll be so funny if like uh all this
stuff happens. There's all these scandals with Twitch and it's
just some random skitsoid diving at Emirou to get a hug. That
is the final nail in Dan Clansy's coffin. That nothing else could
do it. But actually allowing Emiru to be hurt.
Emir, our pride, our queen, our innocence, our collective innocence.
You allowed her to be hurt. She is both She is both child and
paramore to every deranged virgin incel Twitch viewer. Okay?
She is both the daughter and wife of every single one of these
people. And they will not accept Dan Clancy's negligence in protecting
her. Okay? Imagine how you'd feel if it was your daughter. Imagine
how you'd feel if it was your wife. Now, imagine how you'd feel
if it was both.
All right. That's how all of these That's how all of these Emmy
reviewers think about her. Okay? It's very gross. We won't get
too much into it, but
we won't get I I'll leave it alone for now. All right. Hello
everyone. I am okay and thank you all for the kind
Sorry, I cannot respond to them all. Yesterday, the man who assaulted
me was allowed to cross multiple barriers at TwitchCon and even
in front of another creator's meet and greet to grab me and my
face and try to kiss me. Fortunately, he wasn't able to, but
a lot of people have pointed out it could have been a lot worse.
Fortunately, he wasn't able to. Huh?
Uh, okay. All right. Very,
okay. All right. Fortunately, he wasn't able to. I feel like
him grabbing you is bad, and I wouldn't have thought worse of
you if he Okay, it's fine. Uh, I'm I'm obviously shaken up by
what happened, and it's not the first time I've dealt with something
like this. But to tell you honestly, I'm a lot more hurt and
upset by how Twitch handled it during and after the fact. Like
I said, I don't understand how he was allowed to make it to me
in the first place. The security in the clip who reacts is my
own security. It's true my favorite and usual security guard
was banned from holding a stalker's arm or for holding a stalker's
arm to bring him to the police at the at a past TwitchCon.
However, there are at least three or four other TwitchCon security
staff in the area who did not react and let the guy walk away
as you can see in the clip since they don't even appear in the
frame. Lol.
Uh they do appear in the frame. There is one of them there. But
what is that person again? What is that 100 pound girl gonna
do with that? That guy is pretty big, right? That guy looked
like 6'5.
6'5. Like probably 230 at minimum. Maybe 250. That's a big dude.
You need a You need a guy, right? You need a bouncer to grab
that dude and try to subdue him. Anyway, the woman who's walking
me away is my own personal manager. And behind the booth, the
only two people who were checking on me and comforting me were
her and my friend. None of the TwitchCon staff came to ask me
what happened or if I was okay. My friend, who was present, told
me Twitch security were also behind the booth afterwards, joking
about how they didn't even see what happened and immediately
laughing and moving on to talking about something else. Ooh.
That's not good.
Oh, that's like a new detail. That is not great. All right. That
is not ideal.
Anyway, so if no one was checking if I was okay or if I needed
anything and they let the guy run away initially, I have no idea
what anyone hired to keep the event safe was even doing. Lol.
Yeah, that's that's rough, dude.
I think again just the the statement on worldclass teams, right?
Worldclass teams and equipment. Where is the worldass team? Where's
the worldass
Like the guy the guy walked out. By the way, we have footage.
We will get to the footage of him just walking out. He is in
the wind.
Uh I think obviously they should be able to find out who he was.
There's enough people screaming. There's enough angles on his
face. I think they'll find out who the guy is. But Jesus Christ,
like how do you not have anybody from security grab him? Okay,
continuing on. And all of this could be maybe understood. All
right. All of this could be maybe understood
through the lens of like a totally unexpected,
like unwarned of event, right? But that wasn't the case this
time. We had a lot of people actively
actively complaining about the security, saying they could not
be protected.
They did get him hours uh later after he left. Oh, sure. Maybe.
Um yeah, okay, that's fine. Trucker Joe, listen, we're walking
through the timeline and I'm going to get to all that stuff now.
So, we are getting to it. I'm basically speaking from how I'd
seen it last night when he walked out totally untouched.
You have the clips of this dude walking free in the con and then
leaving on his own. I do have those clips, Kger. Yes, we will
get to it.
here's the here's the big part. Okay, this is the this is the
whammy on Twitch right here. I've I've heard. All right. In Twitch's
statement, they said the guy was immediately caught and detained.
I'm sorry, but that is a blatant lie. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. We have to
go We have to go reference Twitch's statement before we continue.
Hold on. Where is Twitch's full statement here? I have it. I
have it. I have it. Here it is. Here's the Twitch statement.
Okay, let's take a look because I don't know. The safety and
security, this was earlier and Emir just just referenced it.
So, let's check it out. The safety and security of all those
attending TwitchCon is our highest priority. The behavior displayed
by the individual involved in the incident yesterday involving
a high-profile streamer was completely unacceptable and deeply
upsetting. In the in line with existing TwitchCon security protocols,
law enforcement and event security were on site and responded
to the incident. We immediately blocked this individual from
returning to the TwitchCon premises and they are banned indefinitely
from Twitch both online and in-person events. We are coordinating
with the impacted creators team and per our standard protocols
continue to cooperate with any law enforcement investigations.
We've increased security at the meet and greet attendee check-in
point and will have additional security personnel surrounding
participating streamers. If you've RSVPd for a meet and greet,
please note that we are unable to accommodate plus ones for the
remainder of the event. Twitch has zero tolerance for harassment
or acts that inhibit the safety and security of our community.
Okay, so let let's see here. uh immediately block this individual.
Is this what she's interpreting as
is this what she's interpreting by appre as apprehended or do
we have another statement from Twitch saying he was apprehended
cuz I actually don't know and that's probably something we need,
right? I don't know if we have
him actually being apprehended somewhere. Do we have anything
to suggest this? Cuz I'm looking for where where is this statement
made that
immediately caught and detained? Where was this statement made?
Uh made, sorry, that he was immediately caught and detained.
Do we have this? If anybody has this, I'd appreciate it. Ban
does imply they know who he is for a fact.
Um I mean, I guess to bar him from returning. I'm I'm curious
if he actually returned though.
Sorry. Going back to the Emmy statement
to say that you've immediately blocked this individual from returning
to the TwitchCon premises. Maybe they knew. Okay. Maybe what
what happened here? Possibly. Okay. Possibly what happened is
they had his username from a check-in somewhere and they banned
that username from being able to check back into the event. Possibly.
Uh I uh I saw a clip of him leaving the con. He did leave the
con. Yes. So I'm guessing maybe as he checked in or out, they
grabbed his name. Maybe they figured out who he was and they
banned him from re-entering. Okay. All right. Let's continue.
We immediately block this individual from returning. Uh and they're
banned definitely from Twitch. both online and inerson events.
We of course the big big news guys, we banned this four follower
skitsoid from ever streaming on Twitch. He will never be able
to stream on Twitch now and and this is this is our best contribution.
because he was only going to be banned from Twitch on for 30
days. Hold on. His Twitch name would be on his badge probably.
They were going to ban him for 30 days. What? Asmin name dropped
the dude. It was the one I heard said he caught he's caught hours
later. Okay. Well, listen. We're we're catching up. We'll figure
this all out. All right.
So, they're banned from indefinitely from Twitch. We are coordinating
with the impacted team's creator and per our
Continue to cooperate with any law enforcement investigations.
All right. We have increased security at the meet and greet area.
Oh, we we actually finished the Twitch post, didn't we? All right.
Twitch allowed the asalent to walk originally and was only pressed
to apprehend him until was only pressed to apprehend him until
Emiru's manager pushed for it. I This is a horrible How is this
even the community note? This is like horrible English. The individual
was allowed to walk originally. Twitch allowed the asalent to
bypass several barriers and creator lines. Emmy retweet on this.
This is not a citation is people's word against uh
I'm going to I'm going to fight. Listen, there's going to be
some part of me in in my heart that is not going to like the
level of diligence that's going into this. There's a lot of emotional
correcting going on, right? Like this is just an emotional correction.
Yes, he originally walked away. We don't exactly know how much
Emir's manager pushed forward or whatever, right? I don't know.
We'll we'll get into it. I would like to see some more evidence
of this stuff.
We're reading we're back to reading Emy's uh Emy's original post.
Okay. So, in Twitch's statement, they said the guy was immediately
caught and detained. I'm sorry, but that is a blatant lie. He
was allowed to walk off from my meet and greet. And I did hear
he was I didn't hear he was caught until hours after he attacked
me. And it felt like this only happened because of my manager
pressing for it, not because TwitchCon staff present thought
it was a big deal. I have a lot more I want to say and will I
will say it on stream later today instead of writing a book on
here. Thank you guys again. Sorry you all had to see that. This
is definitely my last TwitchCon and it saddens me to say that
uh say as a 10-year off and on attendee of TwitchCon. I think
other creators should seriously consider not attending in the
future. I did not feel cared for or protected even bringing my
own security and staff. I can't imagine how creators without
those options would feel. Stay safe, y'all. Everything is going
to be okay. Oh, Twitch. I understand. Listen, Junararch,
if America could justify going to war with multiple countries
over 9/11, then I think we can justify lying to to destroy Twitch
on behalf of Emirou, can't we? It's really like it's not even
in the same stratosphere of crime. Lying about
lying about, you know, people being responsible for 9/11 to facilitate
wars versus just lying about like what happened with Emiru to
get Twitch destroyed because they allowed Emiru to be assaulted.
I mean, realistically, we could totally justify one of these
things in my mind. All right.
Obviously. Obviously. So, what's up, full of hell? How's it going?
How's it going?
Okay, we have we have that Amiru statement. And not only do we
have that statement, we've additionally got Amiru's personal
stream from the day. Now, I think she does multiple statements
throughout this stream. So, I've got both the VOD and the time
stamp. Let's keep it tight to just her talking about the security
situation and then after that we can go back to talking about
possibly something else here. Okay. And Tan Clansy's cut the
We believe Dan Clansancy may have financed these operations.
All right.
Dan Clansancy himself may have had something to do with this.
All right. And even if he didn't, we believe Dan Clansancy also
has plans to allow not just Emiru, but Pokemon, SA, Valkyray,
many of your favorite streamers, maybe of your your totally
totally parasocial waifuss. Dan Clansancy wants all of them assaulted.
Okay, that's what Dan Clansancy wants. That's the world Dan Clansancy
wants and he has to be destroyed before he can allow before he
could be allowed to make that world come to pass. All right.
Dan Clancy has no respect for your relationships with these women.
He does not care that they are the most important things in your
lives. And he will allow their sanctity to be violated again
and again and again until somebody steps up and stops him.
And who will it be? Okay, so this is Amir's stream after she
done the tweet. This is from earlier today. All right. >> Wake
the [__] up, samurai.
We have a city to burn. Okay, so
first of all, you guys will have to forgive me cuz
I'm not meant to be doing streams like this. I meant to be playing
dress up in my room playing video games. Okay,
I did not want to have to do like a >> addressing the drama.
Addressing the drama, guys. We're We're just That's what we're
doing today. Give me one second. I'm just going to restart.
They do need to be restarted here. They're they're clicking or
all of this if you guys can hear it.
>> Stream like this. >> Oh, hold on. It
connects. Okay.
I did not want to have to do like a stream like this. Like it
feels like I'm doing like a press conference or something. But
first of all, uh hope you guys are uh all feeling okay. Sorry
you had to see that. You know what I'm supposed to be doing right
now? Actually, I'm supposed to be going over my run of show for
my TwitchCon show, which uh I am still doing, by the way, because
um of all the work that the production staff and the cosplayers
in it put into it. It's not their fault that happened. I'm still
going to do it. But yeah, I don't even know where to [__]
start. I don't know if you guys can see this. >> Oh, she's
still going to do her cosplay show. That's pretty crazy. I wrote
notes for this because there's so much stuff that I feel like
I needs to be talked about which is also why I was very aggressive
in my tweet earlier today which is I mean you guys know me I
am never like that
but >> uh dude the these lazy losers that they hired for
the TwitchCon staff the the security staff. Okay. Is that a Kakuri
cosplay? Um, I mean it is because it's the exact uniform like
down to multiple details, but I don't know. That also might just
be in her wardrobe as a normal thing to wear. I I think that
staff probably just totally them here, right? They've got they've
got this staff there. They didn't do and then they apparently
laughed about it. And I I guess if Amiru heard that, man, and
she wants to go in on you guys, you're
like, this might actually be the thing that gets this entire
corporation like bundled up, all right, and shipped off.
But I just feel like in a way it's my responsibility. You know
what I mean? Because it's not just about me. Like this could
have happened to anyone
>> Okay. Could happen to anyone. We're going to listen
to Emiru. I just have one final thought. Okay.
The only way Dan Clansancy can get his respectability back. Okay.
The only way he can keep his job is to have a one-on-one
octagon fight to the death with the man who assaulted Emiru.
Okay. And despite against all odds, he has to rise up. He has
to win, okay? He has to win. He has to put this beast, this this
monster, this savage down, okay, for the good of all of Twitch
and and all internet goers. Okay, >> for all we know, this
could have already happened to someone, a small streamer, and
someone just wasn't filming it, which Okay, I'll just I'll just
start this by saying shout out to the guy who filmed it and put
it on Twitter
because last night after this happened, I was thinking like,
like I have to talk about this. Like, people need to know that
this happened. Like, how am I going to do that? And then someone
happened to post it on Twitter. So, thank [__] god
I I didn't have to figure that out myself.
It was all unraveled when it was when it was revealed this person
was a DGR. I don't believe they were a DJer. First of all, they're
white. But um second of all, I believe that is a Techone viewer
100%. Okay, you're wondering the only people obsessed enough
with with Emir would be Steak and Eggs viewers. Okay,
I'm telling you. I'm telling you that's the connection here.
We'll figure it out. Okay, Asminold. Did Asmin Gold put his uh
the guy's Twitch name out? If Asminold put the guy's Twitch name
out, let's go. Let's go through his Twitch follows. If somebody
I've heard this, okay, somebody said, "Asmin Golds, put the Twitch
name out of this guy." Can we go find the Twitch follows? I need
them. We need them now. >> Um, which,
okay, like I said, this is going to be a mess cuz I'm not meant
to be doing these kinds of streams. I don't think that Twitch
would have put out an official statement if that clip wasn't
posted and going viral.
And even after the fact that the clip was posted and going viral,
>> I as far as I know, the other people who had meet and
greets today were not reached out to to ask if they wanted extra
security or if they even wanted to cancel their meet and greet.
Like maybe some people were, but um I know for a fact Extra Emily
wasn't.
>> Okay, so Extra Emily was not given extra security. Twitch.
I believe that was in Twitch's statement, right? That they were
offering extra security for these people. We'll have additional
security personnel surrounding participating
And Ambry was saying, "No, no, no, no. They were not offered
this." Um, my personal manager made sure that she had extra security.
No one reached out to her. Don't know about everyone, but I know
that for a fact. Okay, so let's just start from the beginning.
>> Yeah, Jay. Good. I was uh I was going through tabs and
I had that sitting in a >> cuz I want to have be able to
run through everything before the show starts. The show starts
in a hour.
Okay, my notes are mess. It looks like a skitso board. Um
>> but yeah, again, thank you to the guy that put it on
Twitter. Thank you to the people that talked about it >> because
I don't know if anything would have been done or would have been
taken seriously straight up. So, I'm just going to go through
from my perspective
what happened, what I saw, the order of events. Um, so I was
doing my meet and greet and I've seen people saying that it was
an obligation given to me, uh, like to be a featured creator
and to have my show, I had to do a meet and greet, which is true.
I was told, >> okay, so we got that right. We we figured
that out yesterday. We got it >> told that I had to do
a meet and greet. Um, but as far as I know, there are some people
that cancelled. Regardless, I didn't cancel. I I thought it was
going to be fine. So, um, I show up at 4. I'm doing my meet and
greet. This happened about 30 minutes into my meet and greet.
So, I was probably only like 20 to 30% done with my meet and
greet.
I was just taking a picture with someone else, like completely
normal, nice guy. Um, and then I see out of the corner of my
eye there's a guy
walking around the side of the meet and greet and he crosses
in front of the meet and greet of the person to the left of me
which is a Btuber. So he he's able to walk up and in front of
a >> Oh, she's laying it out. Okay, this is the case we
made yesterday.
Why the is there no barrier between that VTuber's meet and greet
that nobody cares about cuz she can't be assaulted worst case
scenario they knock over a TV or something and Emirus the biggest
female streamer on Twitch by concurrent
>> Another streamer's meet and greet and then he walks
up to me and
he he's like walking with a purpose, you know what I mean? Um,
and he he grabs me, but I'm like, "Wait, what the but in in my
head I'm like it's it seems like he's supposed to be here." And
then he leans and like he's going to tell me something. So in
my head I'm like maybe it's like TwitchCon staff like coming
to let me know something cuz like sometimes it'll happen where
you're at an event and someone will like come up. Oh man, I hate
to say this cuz I'm not giving the guy props obviously in any
way, but the way he walks over the he does the thing. If you've
ever heard about how people like um trying to fake their ways
into concerts and stuff, there's like there's something to be
said for just walking with purpose like you're supposed to be
there. He's not running. He's not frantic. He's calm. He is just
walking through like he has to do that. Like he has a mission,
right? He's got like the eye. He's Yeah, the clipboard high high
viz vest is like what people joke about, but just here he's just
walking with like purpose through this, right? And and that is
what allows him to cut through here. I guarantee if he was like
frantic in some way, people were making a ruckus of any kind,
uh that's he gets like he gets spotted immediately.
It's like the calm but direct and like focused way he walked
through there that nobody even like questions.
>> I'm up to like let you know something. You know what
I mean? But I'm still like freaked out because he grabbed me.
That's not normal.
And then he grabs my face
and he leans in
and lips puckered and tries to kiss me and I start
>> You can't hear it in the clip, but I'm [__]
screaming my head off. And then my security Twitches >> That's
not funny. That's not funny. Nowhere near me. >> He had
the I mean, we could just call this the Teone aura. Okay. He's
Te size. He's Tees build. He had the techone aura. Listen, I'm
telling you this is a this is a techone viewer. Okay, this is
a what do you call them? Egg eggs or >> Nowhere to be found.
I can see them, but they they don't do anything.
Um my security jumps up and shoves the guy away from me and is
like, "Get the out of here." And he's allowed to walk away and
leave. Yeah. So then after this point, I did not see a lot of
what happened here. This is just based off what people in the
line told me. Uh, my friend Bonnie who was there told me and
Melissa, my manager told me. >> So, the the woman who moved
me away from the meet and greet was my personal manager. That
was not Twitch staff. No one in Twitch staff came up to me to
like see what was going on. >> I dude, how is that the
case that not a single person from Twitch directly comes up to
talk to her about this? How is that even remotely possible? How
is that thinkable in this case? Dude, you one of the biggest
creators on your platform is assaulted live on a stream on your
platform live at your event and not a single person thinks, "Oh,
we should probably make sure Emiru is okay. We should probably
offer her whatever we can. Can people go check? Can people go
see what's up?" And then apparently they're laughing about it
behind the behind the scenes. >> Uh my manager and >> absolutely
correct. Green pepper. Eddie would never. Eddie could never.
This would never happen under stake Eddie's watch. Okay. What
do you What would you prefer, guys? A a a website that allows
crypto gambling or a website that allows the salt of their most
popular female streamers. Okay. It's not close. It's obviously
You got to go with Eddie here. Eddie is the superior CEO bar
none. But it's not even close. They're not even in the same ballpark.
All right. Thank God for Eddie. I bet you Eddie will donate for
Emmy's therapy bills, okay? Because he's just that kind of guy.
But he'll do it under he'll do it on the sly. He will never say
that it was him. Eddie will make sure Emir is taken care of because
Eddie is a good person unlike Dan
>> He moved me to the back and they're like hugging me
and being like, "Uh, do you want to finish your meet and greet?"
Basically, um,
>> they tortured a guy to death live on kick in France
and got rewarded for it. Ah, common misnomer. Okay, that person
was planning a similar assault on Pokemon. Okay, Porter Beller,
we've gotten this the just coming in now. Okay, new intel to
the JSTock community desk. That guy was planning an assault on
Pokemon and he got what he deserved. I've been told. Okay.
Yes, sometimes the way you deal with these terrorists is is harsh.
It seems inappropriate, but
but Pokemon safe. Okay. Eddie kept Pokemon safe. And I I was
back there for like a minute and I was like, you know what? Like
I I want to finish it because like of all these people here that
you know, they're just nice normal people. And I go back out
there and still there's no one from Twitch there and the poor
guy that I was taking the picture with originally, he he looks
he's he's like mortified and he's like so he's like, "What the
just happened?" And again,
>> bro. Okay.
Mo biggest unheard of unseen tragedy here is
Listen, Emiru is not with Msk anymore.
This blue-haired guy had the chance to make all of his dreams
come true if he'd managed to react and stand on business for
Emiru. Okay, this is the only chance he'd ever have. The only
fractional
infantismally small chance he had in his entire life. And he
let it come and go. And he didn't do [__] He had
He had the shot. He had the interaction with Emirou. He could
have helped. He could have done something. He could have been
the guy who stood up. Yes. And he missed his shot. All right.
He'll never get it back. That's the only chance he ever had.
All right. He failed the cut scene. He failed the quicktime event.
Okay. He had a quick time event where he could have captured
Emir's heart. The the thing he's wanted more than anything in
his entire life. And he failed the quick time event. He had one
shot
and he blew it. Unbelievable.
>> No one from Twitch there. I I say to this guy, I'm like,
"I'm sorry you had to see that." And he's like, "No, like I'm
so sorry that happened to you. Why am I having to tell
the TwitchCon attendees and my fans, sorry you had to see that,
and not like someone from Twitch or Twitch security."
Anyway, um
so I didn't see this. This is just what
my friend and my manager were telling
>> brutal comment. >> The the Twitch security like
kind of like got together after that and we were like, wait,
what happened? Oh, I didn't even see what happened. Haha. And
just like started talking about something else.
So, it's like, okay. And then that's the the events of what happened
just to like line all that up. But I didn't talk at all about
the aftermath of all of this at all. And I don't think anyone
knows this save for like maybe some streamers that I'm friends
with that came to spend time with me or that >> Okay, so
we're getting more new information. All right, we're getting
the lowdown on the aftermath to >> last night.
Okay. Um, I so I finished the meet and greet and I was escorted
back to my hotel by my one security guard. Oh, and also, by the
way, I uh I've seen clips people bringing up clips of me talking
about how my previous favorite security guard was permab from
TwitchCon
because um at a previous TwitchCon 2 years ago, I believe, I
think it was two years ago, uh there was a stalker and he held
him by the arm until police got there and because of that he
was indefinitely banned from TwitchCon,
like from all of TwitchCon, not just the venue, because that
was in Las Vegas. Anyway, that just just a side note.
Okay, man. I wrote down a lot of here. Okay, can I just also
say what you guys are seeing here is character development.
I've always been the person who
never says [__] like
>> uh it is major. I Dude, we're all
incredibly stunned. All right. We're stunned at your your bravery.
We are so stunned. Okay, Emir, you're doing fantastic. You've
never done anything wrong before. You're doing great right now.
We are all so impressed. And so, >> switchcon 2 years ago,
I believe. >> Hold on. I need to I need to use the bathroom
real quick. I'll just be 2 seconds. I'll be right back. >> Two
years ago, uh there was a stalker and he held him by the arm
until police got there. And because of that, he was indefinitely
banned from TwitchCon,
like from all of TwitchCon, not just the venue, because that
was in Las Vegas. Anyway, that just just a side note.
Okay, man. I wrote down a lot of [__] here. Okay,
can I just also say what you guys are seeing here is character
I've always been the person who
never says [__] Like, I just want everyone to have
fun for things to go well.
Why am I the person who has to do this? So, I Anyway, after I'm
escorted back to my hotel,
um I let some of my friends know they come to my hotel to see
me and spend time with me, like make sure I'm okay and everything.
Um and then my manager's letting me know. She says,
"Okay, I I've she my manager, I've contacted the police. They're
going to come talk to you about pressing charges, etc. They're
trying to find the guy. They haven't found him.
>> I'm like, what?
He
Anyway,
>> Oh, that is a good moment to cut over, too. Okay. I
believe best friend Kick did the tremendous work of tracking
down all of these clips. Okay. Like, I I can't tell you. We We
thought about doing it last night. All right. We thought about
going through a whole bunch of footage from a bunch of different
streamers and seeing if we could actually link this to like some
of the like like back to the Emiru stalker guy and we we couldn't.
Here's uh here's one of the clips and then there's one other
clip here. Let's go over to Oh, we'll cover this Chud clip in
just a second as well. But we got we got this one right here
as well. Okay.
>> # get it. So, we had this guy walking around and you
see the you see the guy walk by in this guy's stream. I don't
even know who this guy is. >> Yeah, I got a hashtag give
it back.
seeing meet and greet was pretty cool
>> That was fun.
>> Saw the homies back there. >> Dude, I can't imagine
what Joe is doing.
>> That was fun as he walks.
>> All right. Now I wonder is there any way to grab his
like name? No, probably not. But he's he's rolling through. >> All right.
Kind of looks like the angry Is it the angry video game nerd?
You guys know who I'm talking about? AVGN angry video game nerd.
Kind of looks >> homies back there.
>> Am I Am I crazy? I feel like there's a total there's
absolutely a resemblance there.
Let me find Let me find a good picture. Okay. Right here. This
picture right here. No, you don't think so? Hold on. Let me pull
up this picture right here. I am Am I crazy on this? Maybe I'm
crazy on this. I somehow thought he looked like that. He has
like some
same haircut. I thought same haircut. Pale looks a little bit
like it. But you know what? I'll let that one go. Maybe maybe
that's not it.
Maybe that's not it.
Hold on. This is him. This him walking out a little bit later.
So we got
>> He powers through this. >> They said [__]
step. Did someone say step in? Do I have seven minutes? How much
time actually? Oh, that's him on his way to the actual assault,
isn't it? So, you see he walks around here. There's There's where
he exits. He's
>> right. You see him come through. He walks all the way
through. He powers across. This is where uh this is where Amiru
is at this second one here. So, this would be the VTuber. This
would be Emiru, right? Or possibly shift them one over because
I can't totally tell with this. This could be this could be them,
but I think this is the Vtuber. Anyway, this these are the lines
for the Vtuber and Emiru. Okay. He powers through from the side.
Doesn't go through either >> [__] step in.
Did someone say step in? Do I have 7 minutes? How much? >> Oh,
this >> time actually. >> It's less than 10 minutes.
>> Wait, are we actually
>> It's over right there. >> Stream is Jover. We
got to head back to
>> You catch it. He sticks out like a sword thumb. Sword
thumb. Sore thumb. He does stick out like a sore thumb because
he's so tall. You could see him over the heads of like everybody,
right? The
>> all right. So, we had these couple of angles of him
walking through. I don't know why this is a screenshot here.
And then we have the the screenshot or sorry, the video of him
walking out.
>> Him walking out of the venue.
>> Totally calmly walking.
>> Bro, if Tyler Robinson had one third of this guy's cool,
he would have gotten away with it. All right. This guy
>> This guy just walked in and out. He was like, "Yeah,
I just I did it." And then he walks out slowly. Okay. He just
he just slowly calmly walks out like he didn't do.
>> Okay. I don't think that's him. The guy the guy didn't
have a beard. Oh, wait. Does this guy have a beard who's walking
out? Hold on.
>> Guys got a beard. Uh, it's possible that's not him.
I don't see a beard here. I see like a shadow. I I don't think
there's a beard on that guy. I think that's a shadow.
Am >> I crazy?
>> Hold on. Let's look at the checker pattern on the shirt
again.
He walks out. We got this checker pattern on the shirt. Let's
all the >> Let's look at this guy.
>> Seeing meet and greet was pretty cool,
>> Got a black shirt. >> Well, it's not buttoned
up.
>> But that that plaid looks to be about the same, doesn't
it? No, I think that's him. I I think that's him. Okay, this
is the guy walking out. All right, that's the guy walking out.
And plot twist plot twist is Jonathan Lane. Dude, Jonathan Lane
cannot appear anywhere else, okay? Okay. Or I'm going to get
pretty skitso about it. We can't see it happen again.
We can't we can't see him again for a while. All right. That
guy cannot just be everywhere. That's [__] crazy.
All right. So, we'll continue on now that now that we've investigated.
Yes, this guy did just walk free. He walked out. They didn't
get him. All right,
let's continue on with station. He
Anyway,
anyway, um
so at at some point while I'm with my friends, a police officer
comes and talks to me, interviews me, interviews my manager,
talks to my uh Twitch partner manager, who by the way, she's
so sweet. Like, she she didn't do anything wrong here. All of
that happens and then I'm complaining. My friends, I'm like,
"The do I do here, guys? Like, I have to I have to talk about
this blah blah blah." And they're like, "Oh, like don't worry
about that right now." And then suddenly wakes like, "Wait, why
is my Discord saying hope Emy's okay?" And I'm like, "Oh, fuck."
I guess the clip got posted again. Thank god someone was filming
because otherwise I don't think Twitch would have sent me a thing.
So after that, I start getting a lot of messages. I'm responding
to people. >> This is the top female streamer on Twitch.
Yeah, you you think Twitch See, I understand that could be confusing.
Do you think Twitch and this stream should be like entertaining
or she should be like, you know, more compelling in the way she
speaks? No. In fact, her her childlike speech pattern is entirely
almost entirely the reason for her, you know, popularity. All
right. Did stream die. Uclid class. Uh, you may have to go to
the Twitch stream. All right. Kick is having issues.
Check
out the Twitch stream if you're having problems.
Okay. Kick's having issues. You might need to check out the Twitch
stream if you're having problems. All right. And my manager comes
back to me and she's upset.
She's like, "Okay, uh, I've been talking to Twitch people and
I'm really upset because
I noticed a lot of negligence around the event and I'm not happy
with the way that they're handling it now." And I'm like, "What
do you mean?" She's like, "Well,
um, I asked them, you know, like what are they going to do about
this?" And you know what they said initially?
They said, "Oh, well, he's banned from the platform for 30 days."
>> Dude, I can I just get a job at Twitch? I I guarantee
you I could replace like five any five r five random employees
at Twitch. I think I could replace them by myself. Like, these
people are so bad at just any amount of critical thinking. It's
so bad. How in the world could you say to her manager who's looking
out for her best interest, "Yes." So, well, you know, we could
do a 30-day ban. We 30-day ban on this guy. 30 30 days. What
do you think? How How you feel? We'll do 30-day ban and we'll
make sure he can only talk to one more egirl at the at the event.
Okay. 30-day ban. And we, you know, we'll we'll prevent him from
going to the Emmy meet and greet. He he had to sign up for it.
Sorry, the uh extra Emily meet and greet. He had to sign up for
it. We'll take that away from him. That's as far as we'll go.
>> What? And then she's obviously like, "Hello." Like,
"That needs to be indefinite. What the you talking about?" Also,
that's like nothing to do with anything. No one gives a if he's
banned on Twitch or not. Like, we're talking about the convention
here. So, they they change it to indefinite.
Takes takes an hour for that to happen, by the way. Uh, these
two people are um the head of >> Oh. Oh, god. She going
to start naming titles. Uh-oh.
Yeah. I'm sorry, guys. I just I can't get over it that like
how how do we explain
to like
to Dan Saltman, okay, in in his mind all of the anti-semitism
on planet Earth couldn't get anything to change at this platform,
okay? Couldn't get a single thing to change. And all it took
was one dude grabbing Emmy and trying to kiss her. And it's like,
oh, actually this is going to upheave the little literally mass
maximum upheaval now. Okay, nobody cared about the Jews. Everybody
cares about Emirou. All right,
it's not close. >> Security for Amazon and the head of
risk for Twitch. >> So, that was head of security at Amazon
and head of risk for Twitch. >> Uh, these two people are
um the head of security for Amazon and the head of risk for Twitch.
>> The head of risk.
Why? Oh boy. What?
I think Silicon Valley has entirely lost the art of like treating
people like humans. Like it is just not a thing that anybody
in Silicon Valley thinks about on a day-to-day basis anymore.
They're just like thinking of humans as totally interchangeable
economic units. And they they they've lost any employees who
think about humanity, too. Like there's just nothing going on
there. Like it's so obvious. You want to send somebody over who's
going to say, "Hey, can I take care of you? Can I make sure you're
okay? Can I like Right." A woman, by the way, send a woman over
who could be like, "Hey, this is horrible. Obviously, we don't
want anything like this to happen." Like, "What can we do to
make this better? What do you need?" Anything like this, right?
None of like none of the people around laughing and be like,
"Oh, we missed it." Whoops. We really [__] up, man.
Cuz the most important product at Twitch is the stock. How does
she look like a hotel bellhop? Uh, because she's doing a cosplay
here. Very likely. Okay. I think somebody pointed this out. It's
It's probably I can't tell if it's an actual cosplay. I can't
tell if it's an actual cosplay or like a joking cosplay,
but it like it kind of hits
kind of hits. Can I get the Can I get the somebody with an untied
tie, right? It do kind of be it do kind of be hitting almost
exact. All right. It's like it's like one to one on this guy,
right? It's even the black the black like lapels are the same.
Anyway,
we continue.
Also, later the same night, I'm not going to drop names here
because I wasn't there, so I didn't see it, but I had multiple
people tell me that key Twitch representatives last night were
out partying. Okay. >> Okay. Hey, >> also another
detail, sorry, my my lines are all crazy here. Um
Um my Twitch TW >> Oh, listen. This is not She's doing
the Donald Trump move, okay? She knows that you can't just say
that they wanted this to happen. You have to show them the Twitch
employees celebrating. Okay, this is like the the Muslims dancing
on 9/11 when they heard about the attacks. Twitch executives
literally went out to party to celebrate Amir being violated.
This company needs to be reh over overhauled,
retoled,
reconstructed, or sorry, restructured as Pokemon would put it.
Okay, we need this company restructured now. Dancing Clancies.
Bro, this is >> didn't approach my manager to talk to their
head of security. It took them 2 hours to approach her to talk
about what happened and by then she had
>> we're hearing we're hearing just into the the JST crisis
desk. Okay. Key Twitch reps dancing after hearing the news about
Emirou dancing about hearing of Emiru's assault. This is crazy.
This is This company is totally It's It's too far gone. Okay,
there's no helping it. This company's got to go. All glory to
Kick. Everybody switch to Kick. All right, it's over for Twitch.
>> Already talked to police and called a lawyer on her
own, my manager Melissa. And uh they showed her a photo of the
guy that I I believe a fan took. By the way, a fan took a photo
of him, not one of their security guards. They're like, "Oh yeah,
here's his photo. Uh we're like going to find him." He still
had his badge and his wristband and everything, the guy. So,
um, yeah, I I really feel like a lot of this process wouldn't
have happened if it weren't for my manager advocating for me
so hard, which again, I'll get to that later. I I'll keep going
here. So, they they also showed my manager um some security footage
of the area and the
>> Oh, well, that cuts way too soon. What the hell? What
do you Why did that cut so quickly? Okay, hold on. Let's go to
the Twitch VOD. We got the Twitch VOD for a reason, guys. Let's
go. Let's go to it right now. That was a crazy
>> How How in the world do you cut it >> I was through
like the two lanes of uh meet and greet people who had >> All right,
hold on. We need to We need to figure out where this was when
we cut out. I sent you part two. Oh, there's a part two. >> hold
on. >> I'll get to that later. >> There's a part
two. We continue >> with a YouTube video. Let's go. >> I'll
get to that later. Oh, I'll keep going here. >> Okay, we
got it. >> So, they they also showed my manager um some
security footage of the area and the guy was able he was waiting
for there to be a gap in security and there was he was able to
walk through the
>> reviewer who just joined. What is going on? Um we're
reviewing Amiru's statements from after her assault. Okay. She
had the strength and the resolve and the grace to go live the
next day. All right. And we are just absorbing that and and trying
to make sure that we retain all of this information. Okay. >> Side,
not through like the two lanes of uh meet and greet people who
had signed up and been like background checked for my meet and
greet.
He was able to just walk through because there just wasn't like
consistent security there.
Oh my gosh. And then um so yeah,
that's
my day yesterday. And then today, um, >> oh, hold on. Amir
was told, okay, if you wanted, if you wanted any evidence, all
right, if you wanted any evidence that Emir is now officially
coming for Dan Clansy's head, all right, apparently
apparently the party she's referring to specifically is Dan Clansancy.
Okay,
>> security for Amazon and the head of risk for Twitch.
Yep, that was who.
>> I was going to leak it to my friend, but I guess I don't
have to now. >> So, later the same night, I'm not going
to drop names here because I wasn't there, so I didn't. >> That's
who they were. >> But I had multiple people tell me that
key representatives last night were out
>> She's speaking about Dan Clancy himself, by the way.
>> I told you. I told you Dan Clansancy was celebrating.
I told you Dan Clansancy was help was happy about this. And now
we get it here. Okay, Dan Clansancy upon hearing this news literally
bought shots for an entire bar. This is what I'm being told.
Okay, he bought shots for the entire bar, doubles for everybody
upon hearing the news.
>> was out partying at an influencer event while this was
happening. >> Sorry, my my lines are all crazy here.
>> I'll say that one. >> The head of security for
Amazon. >> All right, so apparently it was Dan Clansancy.
That's who she was referring to when when she says executives
were out partying >> this morning.
Uh I was told that
um Amazon
flew in
global head of something to redesign the whole process and security
of the con for the rest of the convention.
Why wasn't there someone like that here already? Or like they
didn't do that beforehand? Like, hello. I'm sorry. Um, so yeah,
they I guess they know that they up really bad if they're flying
in their global Amazon's global head. >> Yeah, I'm guessing
they realize I'm guessing they realize that this is a problem
now. Um, I would ask, okay, if they had a world-class team, how
did it not involve Amazon's global head of security? If they
had a world-class team planning this, where was that guy? Why
wasn't he there?
And also I I want to make it clear so that people understand
this.
I am so
lucky and privileged. Okay? Do you know how much I spent on security
to be able to come to this event in the first >> Like but
I I'm not just talking about yesterday. I'm talking about my
security for like my RV trip that I did with my friends and stuff.
>> I spent over $10,000.
Some people who stream on Twitch don't even make $10,000 in a
year.
What the are they? >> That's in fact that is most people
who stream on Twitch >> is supposed to do like if you watch
the clip
the security guard who pushes supposed to do like if you watch
the >> Hold on. Hold on. >> What the Some people
who stream on Twitch don't even make $10,000 in a
>> Some people who stream on Twitch don't even make $10,000
in a year. I assume she means streaming. Okay. No, that's actually
like 99.9%
of people who stream on Twitch. That's me, by the way. I don't
make $10,000 a year on Twitch. >> What the [__]
are they supposed to do? Like, if you watch the clip, the security
guard who pushes the guy away is my security. The woman who pulls
me to the back, my manager.
If you're a small streamer and you don't have those resources
or someone in your line's not filming, what the do you do?
No one would have known. Like, it it's it's actually insane.
Like I like I I'm genuinely angry. Like I am not an angry person.
Like it it's just ridiculous. And like honestly,
>> uh it seems we are getting Hold on. We're getting live
footage right now, guys, of Dan Clansancy and his celebration.
Okay, I'm told this is seconds after being told of Emiru's assault.
We have this live footage of Dan Clansancy from seconds after
being told Emiru was assaulted. He took his his he took his elation
and he translated that into more assaults. Okay? More harm done
to women who stream on his >> Guys, I am not a trained
professional. Don't try this at home.
>> Could this be? >> No. Dad, put her down. Dad,
don't power bomb her.
But the third group, >> so not only was he dancing in response
to Emiru being assaulted, he in fact was assaulting, he was furthering
the attacks on female Twitch streamers.
Totally disgusting. Totally
Oh, whoops. Wrong video. Wrong video. Back to Amiru. >> I
I genuinely >> That's an old clip. Sorry, Barry Q. I'm
doing a lot of satire here, okay? Cuz I assume most of us know
that's an old clip. Yes, that's an old clip. No, just real quick.
I don't believe Dan Clansancy was actually dancing and celebrating
when Emiru was assaulted when he was when he received that news.
We're doing a bit, okay, this is a joke. If you can't tell it's
a joke, you're probably a little too participate right now. Don't
worry, later on I'll be doing some like super dry stock market
stuff. You can come back then. I think there have been other
people who have been assaulted, groped, like
who [__] knows worse at these conventions and just
nobody knows because like I said, they didn't post any kind of
announcement, weren't letting other streamers with similar events
as me, similar meet and greets know until there was like a viral
clip.
And by the way, they they can't even mention my name in it. Thank
you guys. Thank you. And okay, hold on. Let me let me pull up
what they wrote because
that that was another thing that was crazy to wake up to. Um,
>> all right. Let me read this. The safety and security
of all those attending TwitchCon is our highest priority. The
behavior displayed by the individual involved in the incident
yesterday with involving a high-profile streamer was completely
unacceptable and deeply unsettling. Okay, so she's she's evaluating
the latest Twitch statement. >> In line with existing TwitchCon
security protocols, law enforcement event security were on site.
That's a lie. That's literally a lie. And responded to the incident.
We immediately blocked this individual from returning to the
TwitchCon premises and they're it banned definitely from Twitch
both online and inerson events. Okay. Like no one cares about
online. We are according with the impacted creators team. That
that's true. and per our standard protocols, continue to cooperate
with any law enforcement investigations.
We've increased security at the meet and greet attendee check-in
point and we'll have additional security personnel surrounding
participating streamers. If you've RSVPd for meet, please note
that we're unable to accommodate plus ones for the remainder
of the event. You know why they said that? They only they only
thought about that because of Melissa, my manager. She said,
"Were you vetting people coming through the line?" They said,
"Oh, yeah. everyone had to sign up and uh they get >> Oh,
this is not like a plus one. Although, this could be another
issue that they could run into. That would be less of an issue
because obviously the plus ones would be known to the other streamers.
They're not going to go commit a crime and try to get away or
something, right? Um I didn't see that. So, obviously that's
not going to happen. I don't think that's as big a risk as they're
making it seem like. I think the big issue here is the fact that
somebody just walked around the lines. Okay. So, you have all
of your security focused on these lines and then you don't even
force people to funnel through those lines to get to the front
and then cut across and see one of these people, right? Like
like there is no like it was horribly set up. This guy just cut
this guy just walked over to the side and was like, "Oh, well,
there's no there's no barrier here." And then he walked through
and and grabbed
>> Get background checks, but uh they're allowed to bring
a plus one. Well, are there plus ones background checked? No.
Melissa was like, "Okay, guys. Um,
Twitch has zero tolerance for harassment or accident inhibit
the safety and security of our community."
yeah. Um,
yeah. I I don't even know. Like, I'm I'm just tired, guys. Like,
>> I'm just so tired of I I've just had so many things
happen. And like, you know, stuff just happens like especially
when you're like a >> stuff be happening. Wiser words have
never been said. Stuff do be happening. >> Creator or like
a girl creator in particular. But I just feel like I've been
failed so many times or lied to so many times and I'm always
like, you know, it's okay. We'll figure it out.
You should have figured it out already.
Oh my god. So yeah. Um, that's basically if unless I'm forgetting
something, a rundown of every >> See, I will say normally
in these situations, what I'll say is if you want to be angry
at somebody, you should have like examples of bad things they
did like poor like basically things to criticize. If you just
want to that something bad happened despite people making their
best effort or doing everything reasonable,
right, then that's a problem. That that's doesn't make sense.
But in this case, it seems like Twitch didn't even come close
to doing everything reasonable to protect this creator specifically
or maybe even most of the, you know, highlighted creators they
had at the event.
This is this is the issue. I'm just kidding full of hell. I don't
think she has to be perfect. I'm just I'm meing. Okay, chill,
bro. You think we don't like Emiru here? How many times do we
have to defend this person for misk before you admit we like
Emmy here? Okay. Uh yeah, I saw the Taylor Loren Taylor Loren
has interviewed Dan Clansancy. We will check that out as >> Everything.
Um, but yeah, it's just it's
insane. And I mean,
I'm not usually the type of person to talk about this stuff,
but it's like, well, did I lie about anything? No. Like, what
are you going to you going to be mad at me for telling like the
things that y'all did wrong? And like, okay, >> I will
say uh there's a hypothe hypothetical scenario here where she
mishars the Twitch staff. She doesn't know that they were laughing
at her. She hears it that way and it's like sort of out of context,
right? And those people are just now. Those people are totally
It's totally over for them. It's so over for those people. There's
no way you could fight the public opinion on this, right?
Like Emiru says she heard them say that. there will never be
a like a a like a dispute of that regardless of what the reality
was there, right? And certainly I would imagine if she'd just
been assaulted and she's emotional, there's a chance she misheard
whatever they were talking about, right? But it will never matter.
It will never matter what they were actually saying ever. It'll
just be if things are like for them. Okay, so another thought
that I had was like maybe
maybe like the reason Twitch said in their thing like oh security
immediately got the guy maybe like you know they hired like security
and they like lied to them so they wouldn't like you know
>> he didn't engage the guy for like five plus seconds.
In fact, Maximus, so this is another thing. In fact,
uh, that was her private security that didn't grab the guy or
sorry, that didn't save her,
right? Her private security failed here, too. >> You know,
lose their job or not get paid. Maybe if you guys had like, you
know, actual
cameras and like good comms, no one would be able to lie or have
to lie. Like why
why is it better to or like easier to find out something happened
in [__] Among Us than at TwitchCon? Hello. >> Why
why is it easier to figure out what happened in a 10erson video
game where nobody's under stress in a in a real tangible way
than it is to at a thousand multiple thousand person conference?
Why is it harder to H? That's a that's a good question actually.
I appreciate that she asked that question. I think nobody had
been asking that question. That is a good question to ask. It's
[__] insane. But yeah, um I just want to tell you
guys all that this is character development. I'm I'm [__]
>> uh it wasn't her usual one. Yeah. No, it was just wasn't
the one. Sorry. It wasn't the one that she like liked. She had
other security. If she uses, you know, the other guy who's banned
from TwitchCon and for everything else, then yeah, I would say
that. I have no idea if she keeps using the other guy, right?
Like I I don't know if she would use the private the the private
security guard she liked from before. If she still uses him for
everything, then yeah, she's probably prevented from rehiring
him. If she just moved on to somebody else and it's this guy
and this guy goes with her everywhere, then I would say no, that
guy wasn't really it wasn't really an >> Sick of it. I'm
so sick of it. Like this this was just the final straw for me.
Oh my goodness. But yeah, um I have been
Okay, some something else. Sorry. I just I just keep remembering
a bit. It's going to be like this for the rest of the stream.
Uh
I saw a thing that said I was in their like top five or top five
or top 10 most followed streamers attending this event. Again,
if that happened to me, what the is happening to small creators
that we don't even hear about because no one's filming them.
Like they tweet it and like Twitch doesn't feel the need to follow
up with them or publicly.
>> Oh boy. Hey, do you guys remember the woman who was
assaulted? We saw that like kind of creepy hug assault that happened
at TwitchCon last year. Do you guys remember that? The guy he
he was just like a creepy guy. He was like a 100 viewer streamer
or something and he like hug like groped this girl and I wonder
if Twitch ever followed up with that girl. I think he got timed
up. He got banned for some period of time, right? But man, she
might be coming forward and saying, "No, I I talked about it.
I was the smallest streamer. They did nothing for me." Dude,
the stuff's going to pile up right now. Anybody who's ever had
anything happen at TwitchCon, they're coming forward. I think
Twitch is Twitch is going to get totally buried by this. I think
this is the one where I'm like, you know what? I don't I don't
think I think we're under
we're under
estimating I'll say how big this is going to be for Twitch. I
think people might be underestimating. I think this is actually
the one. And it's cringe cuz we watched, you know, people sort
of lie to try to get Twitch taken down. This one's bad. This
one's an unforced error. They really could have done a better
job here. And I think we're gonna see a lot of people claim victory
if this actually hurts Twitch in a tangible way. If Dan Clancy
gets fired and it's gonna be like, "Oh, it was nothing you guys
did at all." >> It's just
Yeah, I think I covered everything. And
I've uh been a streamer on Twitch for 10 years. I attended the
very first or maybe the second TwitchCon ever in a 2016 2015.
And um
yeah, like I I understand back then it was different, but I I
feel like
there like I know they say there's security upgrades, but it
really feels like there's not like another thing that um happened
I forgot to mention.
So the way that the meet and greet worked is like people light
up, they come through, they take a picture, then they're supposed
to >> Oh, Porter Beller wants to bet against um Porter
Beller wants to bet against me. I I've learned something, Porter
Beller. I never bet against the nothing ever happens Chud. Okay?
Even if I think this is the time he dies, I never bet against
him. I will never bet against him again because ultimately,
as we've all heard, okay, from a wise man, the ark of history
bends towards the nothing ever happens Chud. Okay. >> Walk
through the back and leave. There were people walking through
the back trying to come up to my booth or like I mean, not all
of them were like malicious intent obviously. Like some people
would leave and be like, "Oh [__] my picture is bad.
I'm going to go back and ask for another one." And my manager
had to be the one to tell them like, "Oh, no. You can't like
keep moving." And there was even like I think it was neon was
able to walk through the back through the back of my meet and
greet and was like, "Oh, hey, like can I come say hi?" And it's
like, "What the fuck?"
Like >> neon disgusting. >> Oh my god. It It was
just horrible. Like there was no >> Emiru. Emirou the worst
thing in Emiru's mind. Okay, you guys won't even believe this,
but an Indian was allowed to walk behind my booth and ask me
to meet me and and talk to me publicly. Can you guys imagine
that? They let an Indian man come up to me.
God. Okay, Emiru. Emu, stop. Emiru, this is not good for your
public image. Just chill, please. >> No thought put into
it at all. And you Yeah, I was like, man, it's just
it's just naked and afraid out here. Like, thank God I have my
manager and my security and my friends.
But like, who is Neon? Neon is Oh, jeez, my kick chat is [__]
up. But, uh, Neon is the the kick streamer, the Aiden Ross friend
who viewed his way into like millions of dollars in fame. Like
the the number one most grown the streamer most benefited by
viewbots ever, okay, is Neon. He used to scream at people a lot.
He's could be funny in his like own cringe element. He's like,
just Google him. Neon streamer. Okay. >> I just feel so
bad. >> Aiden Ross, buddy. >> You know, Twitch creators
who wouldn't be able to be in that position. Are you okay, though?
Um,
this is going to sound up. Honestly, I'm so desensitized to stuff
like that that when it happens, I kind of just go into like lock
in mode. I'm like, "Okay, I need to just lock in and like get
through this."
Oh my god. >> Worry about it later. So that's how I was
able to finish my meet and greet. Like my friends were telling
me like, "Bro, if it was me, I would have been crying. You're
built different for going back out there." And like I said, I
was going back out there and having to apologize to people in
my own mind being like, "I'm sorry you saw that. I hope you're
okay." And then they of course were like, "What the [__]
Why are you saying that to me?" But I felt like I had to because
no one else was there.
>> That's uh that's pretty brutal. I actually feel bad
for that. I know a lot of people do that, right? they they have
that instinctive I think that can be a rough thing when you have
something bad happen to you is um
is you feel like you need to calm other people down by assuring
them you're okay. I think that's a very common like coping mechanism
is you'll have people around you like usually this is with people
and they like fall down and hurt themselves or something. everybody
comes around, you have to like reassure all these people you're
okay. That I think that can be tough, right? When you when you
talk about something really bad happening, just having to like
that can I've heard people describe that fatigue of like I just
don't want to have to calm people down when it's me that's hurt.
So, I think that would be kind of rough having to go through
that after this happened.
>> And uh like I said on Twitter, um
like I really wish I didn't have this opinion. Like I love trying
to be like the positive like, "Oh, let's get together and have
fun everyone."
Uh, I really like would discourage other creators from going
back to TwitchCon, not just because
it was able to happen at all and what happened during it and
the aftermath. Like, it's it's just crazy. Like, why why why
would their PR team say that? like you can literally see in the
clip that he's allowed to walk away. But yeah, um thank you guys.
Um
appreciate all the support and stuff. It was pretty crazy um
getting all the messages and stuff last night. And again, I've
said it like five times. Thank God that someone was filming and
decided to post it because if not, you know what I would be doing
today? I would be so stressed being like, "Okay,
do I have to disrupt my stuff that I >> I just updated
my title for uh to put dancing Clansancy. Okay,
can you guys imagine can you guys believe the Dancing Clansancy
story? I can't believe it that he he literally heard about this
assault and decided he was still going to go party. He decided
in fact to buy shots for everybody in the bar that he was at.
>> Truly disturbing stuff. announce that this thing happened
to me and let people know that it could happen to them.
So, thank God for that guy. Like, thank you so much for doing
that. Um,
I would just encourage everyone just to stand the up,
stand up for yourself, stand up for other people, cuz if you
don't, look what happens. Which is crazy because
I saw Valkyrie. I saw >> stand up for people. If because
if you don't look at what >> other people cuz if you don't
look what happens which is crazy because
I saw Valkyrie I saw Pokey I saw Hassan I saw cutie saying I
don't really want to go to TwitchCon because I don't feel safe
and everyone was saying that they were stupid or overreact not
everyone but a lot of people. Dude, I I love that that the fact
that there's that clip of Emmy explicitly saying, "Um, I kind
of want to cancel my meet and greet, but I have to keep my show,
my cosplay show, so I guess I won't. I guess I'll go do it. I
hope it's all all okay." And then she gets assaulted. Oh, boy.
>> A large portion of people were saying that. And Twitch's
response to that was to be like, "Oh, don't worry everyone else.
Uh, we up security. I should have listened to them." >> Well,
you tried to listen to them. >> Tried to cancel the show.
A lot of people know stuff like this has happened to me in the
past and I just keep going. Like I'm I'm the kind of person that's
like, you know what? I'm not going to let a person or thing ruin
my life or like what's going on for me. You know what I mean?
[__] we ball.
So I was like, I'm going to go anyway. I'm just going to be smart.
I'm going to pay for security. Uh I'm only going to do my show.
How is someone going to attack me at my show? I'm only going
to do my meet and greet. How the [__] would they
get into a meet and greet? It's it's roped off with security.
>> Nope. Lesson learned. Um, and also after it happened,
uh, Twitch did offer if I wanted some of their Twitch security.
I was like,
I'm good, bro. But I was lucky enough that, um, Clemens, who's
one of my usual security guards, flew out from Austin, Texas
this morning to be there with me
>> Oh, have to go to like >> So, one of her usual
security guards actually flew in to make sure that she was going
to be made safe. Okay, she's going to be kept safe now. Does
she not realize her fans are weird? What could What could be
wrong with fans who want to meet me? No, she knows. We covered
actually I I don't know if you were watching last night, but
we actually covered the DMs of her and Miskip discussing. Mskip's
like, "Hey, stop yourself on stream. You said you didn't want
these weirdo fans." And she's like, "Well, I didn't really think
about it." Yeah, I don't really want these weirdo fans anymore.
>> Mike's like that. And I have two other security guards.
One of them's Amazon's, but I have my personal security guard
I feel comfortable with is like my main guy.
Um, and they said that they like change security for the show
and stuff. But yeah, I'm I'm just done. Like
this is the kind of thing that it's like once you break the trust
for something like this, you're you're never getting it back.
I'm sorry. You're just not like it's not like this is the first
time that something like this has happened. So like the trust
was already kind of broken and that caused a lot of people not
want to come. Like for example,
people were talking about how last >> I just I can't wait.
All I all I know for sure is the thing that caused the trust
to start eroding was that TwitchCon, where the kick streamers
were going and pressing um Twitch streamers, right? So, I just
feel like none of these people could justify a move to Kick,
the company that technically paid the people who were doing those
tactics, right? There's no there's no way. And listen, I don't
think Kick was really responsible and they tried to ban people,
but I just feel like if you're gonna be mad at Twitch, certainly
you must also be mad at Kick, right? Certainly.
I guess YouTube's the only home for these people. >> Last
year, uh Nick, Nol, and Wake
>> Yeah, look, she's talking about it now. >> I literally
walked up to Nick on stream and licked his nipple, which again,
if that wasn't filmed on stream, would anything have been done?
I don't [__] know. And they didn't even make like
an official announcement about it. They didn't reach out to Nick
as far as I know. He was saying that last year. So I if they
did reach out to him, it was way after the con. So it's like
did they just not think it was a big deal? Is it because Nick's
a guy?
hello.
Like I'm supposed to be working on my run of show right now.
Um
I am still doing the show like I said because of uh the production
staff worked really hard on it. and the cosplayers involved worked
really hard on it. So, I I still want to do it, but this is going
to be my last TwitchCon show. I'm doing it with Baby Nani and
Will Nef. So,
even though we haven't really had time to go over this in practice,
uh it'll be fine. It'll be a show, but it'll be fine. I'm sure
it'll be fun. Um
lots of talented people working in Twitch production and uh
all that.
It's uh
>> she sounds she she sounds like she really believes this.
>> Uh Hassan brought up Darius when he watched this. I
mean, listen, there's there's a couple different things going
on there where I think it's weird for Hassan to bring it up like
directly in this context. And yet, I think there's some weird
with Darius and Destiny doing there's some weird [__]
there that might be kind of relevant. I'm not going to go into
it right now because I think this is more about a very specific
problem to Emirou. This seems way more like the um the idol culture
that happens in Asia, right? This seems way more like that, like
somebody who is obsessed with her in a romantic sense trying
to to do something. It's it's like a different kind of problem.
So >> anyway, um how we feeling guys?
Uh yeah, I'm flying home tomorrow and my security guard's going
to be accompanying me to fly home. But it's it's just sad
the world that we live in now. Like to me, I I don't even think
of myself as like
>> uh I believe the cosplay event is either happening right
now, Creger, or has already happened. So, we'll we'll check that
out in just a minute. >> That needs to be protected or
like someone important. But it's like,
you know, I was talking about how like I wanted to buy a new
hamster recently.
I was thinking about how if I if I want to do that on stream,
I'd have to hire security to go buy a hamster.
And like I said, I spent over $10,000 alone just to come to TwitchCon
for
I probably spent close to six figures
total going to cons
and uh stuff on security. And again,
it's not like this only happens to people of my >> I I
this is like I don't like these points. They're fine to make
like whatever she's making them. But the reason she spends so
much money is because she is so big. The problem scales, right,
with the amount of money you're making essentially. She has so
many people watching her, following everything she does, liking
her stuff, giving her donations that she needs more security
than the average person would have. That's why she has to spend
so much money on security is because she has a massive following.
She makes a massive amount of money, right? So, I just I think
there's and whatever she was like assaulted yesterday, so there's
some amount of letting that go, but
I just think I personally think that this is not really a great
point that the, you know, 10 viewer streamer doesn't need $10,000
security to keep them safe. >> Size, this happens to to
girls or guys with 50 viewers. What the [__] are
they supposed to do? They can't afford that. It's like you got
to just deal with it. not there or you're that's another thing.
I could have [__] died
>> I mean, isn't the other situation they were in with
the guy who like chased them around the amusement park? Wasn't
that way worse?
It seems like if you just have like a deranged stalker who is
going to follow you and try to chase you no matter what. Um,
most systems aren't really set up to deal with that very well.
Maybe there's some awareness that should be, you know, raised
around, hey, this is a different type of security problem where
these people aren't trying to get away. They're not even trying
to really do anything, right? They're they're literally willing
to give up their lives to try to like touch this person. It's
a very different security problem than you deal with in a few
other in a lot of other cases where you're just thinking about
how to manage the crowd so bad things don't happen. >> But
yeah, um obviously
I'm going to be making my own personal changes going forward.
I already have like
for years, but I'm just really hurt and disappointed
by
how everything was set up by Twitch and like how it was handled
after.
Um, like honestly that ups was upsetting me more and making me
more angry last night than everything else. >> Speaking
this up because we're kind of circling the drain. She's reiterated
this stuff a couple times and I want to get to that Taylor Loren
Dan Clansancy question. Okay. Taylor Loren interviewed Dan Clansancy.
Osama bin Clansancy. Some people are calling him. The man who
planned and perpetrated the October 17th attacks on all of our
hearts. Okay. The man who danced in the streets. The dancing
Clancy himself. Okay. After hearing of the attack success. We're
going to get an interview with him and Taylor Loren coming up
in just a second. So, I'm going to speed this up and we'll get
to it. >> You know, person can be walking on the street
and get assaulted. Like, yeah, it's horrible. It's [__]
horrible. But why do I have to worry about that happening at
the convention for the place that I work? I don't know if I'm
just talking in circles now, but um I don't know, guys. Um
y'all want to see my fit for the show?
>> Okay, so this is their fit for the cosplay show. All
right, so that's it for the Emmy Rou statements.
>> Let's uh let's continue on with the rest of the show,
guys. We've got reactions from a bunch of people today. I'm also
looking if anybody's got the Asen Gold reaction. I'll probably
go look through some of the Asmin Gold stuff just just to see
from some of his unique stuff from today. But we need to go to
the big one. Okay, this big one right there.
What the Oh, somebody linked me some Spider-Man clip earlier.
>> Okay, so we got two minutes. Ted Loren met up with Dan
Clansancy and asked about Twitch's safety post Emiru
>> Let's Let's give it a listen. >> Obviously, we
saw one Twitch streamer yesterday, Emiru, get assaulted by a
male fan. And a lot of streamers have, especially female streamers,
have talked about, you know, the danger that they feel from these
sort of toxic, I guess, parasocial kind of creeps. What are you
guys doing to prioritize safety? Cuz I know also a bunch of Twitch
content creators said that they were too scared to even come
to TwitchCon this year, just in case something like what happened
yesterday would happen. >> The safety of our creators.
>> Okay. It seems like the Twitch I don't know if you guys
are not typing in Twitch chat. Oh yeah, I just got a thousand
kick chats in a row. Sorry, I meant the kick chat. There's something
weird going on with kick right now. >> I I need to back
it up.
What are you guys doing to prioritize safety? Cuz I know a bunch
of Twitch content creators said that they were too scared to
even come to TwitchCon this year just in case something like
what happened yesterday would happen. >> The safety of
our creators is the top priority. The challenge we face is a
challenge in today's society. It's not limited to Twitch. It
extends throughout our society. I do think that when you're live
streaming in many ways since you control your community and you
can ban people you can make it so that those people that you
don't want >> so their top priority okay even though he
was out partying last night instead of checking in on Emmy he
says his top priority is the safety of the streamers >> engaging
with you and >> very interesting Dan Clansancy I feel like
we have a lot of reason to doubt this like you have not made
sure Emmy is >> participating with you aren't there okay
it's very different you know when I use other short form content
and people say all sorts of stuff. Well, I can't stop that. But
when I live stream, they basically don't bother me. Now, what
happened yesterday obviously was something that we care deeply
about securing this environment. You know, we're looking very
closely at everything that happened there and I care deeply about
Emmy. She's a friend of mine and so I want to see how we can
support her. This is just something we have to keep working on.
And I think everyone identifies our tools in terms of trust and
safety as the leaders in the industry about helping creators.
But that means there's
>> I don't think that's true. Wait, I don't think that's
true at all. In fact, I think there's been persistent complaints.
I thought some unfairly about your security since last year.
And there doesn't seem to be unless you could tell us about some
new in steps you instituted that could deal with this kind of
problem. I don't know. I don't know where you're going with this.
I just I can't tell if he
I honestly can't tell if he thinks like this is an appropriate
response or not. This is not appropriate. Bro, you need to chill
with the PR responses. Honestly, the first thing you should do
here is not you shouldn't even lead with like Yeah, you should
you should lead with the Emir is a thing. Um, we need to make
sure she's taken care of right now. We need to fix that problem.
And we've totally we totally failed on that. We totally failed
Emiru, right? you need to like come and say yes I up weed up
top down we need to reevaluate our approach because this happened
and we have to have a no like we have to do everything we can
to prevent this from happening like just take responsibility
for it and then do the explanations after for like right off
the hop okay don't just say we're industry leaders after we watch
somebody get assaulted bro like hey
after 9/11 do you think it would be appropriate for the TSA to
come out and go guys we're industry leaders in security approaches
to to securing flights. All right? And we understand weed up
this one time and we understand that you're upset, but like we
are the industry leaders. Everybody looks to us for how to secure
flights.
No, that's not the time, okay, after the tragedy. That's not
the time to say you're the best. It's the time to go, oh, weed
up. We failed in our core critical mission and we need to address
what's going on >> There's always more work to be done
cuz that's the world we live in now. Demi had posted earlier
today that I guess this fan was allowed to cross multiple barriers
at TwitchCon. Why should streamers trust Twitch to keep them
safe at TwitchCon? Cuz I feel like simultaneously this has been
such a secure event to the point that even like journalists have
had struggle like you know it is very secure. But here's this
man that just walks up and is somehow able to bypass all these
things. So why should they trust the platform when slip-ups or
you know issues like this have happened? >> Well, I mean
as you know I think you to some of what we do in terms of security.
The reality is even as you do a lot in terms of security in today's
world there are challenges that can present themselves especially
when someone is putting themselves out there right and so you
know we try to work very closely with each creator about what
they want to do and what works for them right so I don't want
to get into any you know specifics or details but part of that
is working with creators and you know trying to >> I mean
I think I need some more details dude I we all feel like I think
everybody's looking for more details here. Like it seems like
a lot of people are saying Twitch can't protect them and and
creators are scared. Creators were already dropping out of the
event before this and this couldn't have possibly helped. How
do you get that trust back? Well, part of that is talking to
creators and making sure that they get what they want and you
know, bro, is this guy is this guy's brain functioning
>> themselves out there to security. The reality is even
as you do a lot in terms of security in today's worlds, there
are challenges that can present themselves, especially when someone
is putting themselves out there, right? And so, you >> I
would say you have a bar for this. There are already countries
with extremely dense events for very popular people who handle
security like this already explicitly. Go look at every Japanese
con that exists and figure out, go talk to them. You want to
know who's actually the the leaders in this? It's Kamaket in
Japan, right? That's who the leaders. The fact that there aren't
like eight slayings at Kamicette every single year is a testament
to Japanese efficiency and how they keep people safe there. All
right. Like it's crazy the level of DGEN loser, have nothing
to live for, totally parasially engaged with the creator types
go to those events and nobody gets hurt or there's very rarely
somebody getting hurt there. Or maybe, you know, don't quote
me, possibly Japanese people just don't care about getting roped.
That might also be the alternative, but it's wild to me that
that he's saying we're the leaders and oh, ultimately, if you
put yourself out there, there's not much we can do. It's like,
bro, this is not you're not making anyone feel safe here.
I You should have You should have canceled this interview or
something. I think this was a horrible interview to take at this
time. This is absolutely going to be weaponized against you.
You're on this one. We try to work very closely with each creator
about what they want to do and what works for them, right? So,
I don't want to get into any, you know, specifics or details,
but part of that is working with creators and, you know, trying
to find and right now we're definitely, you know, ramping it
up to make sure creators know that we have the resources there
to help them figure out what's right for them. >> Okay,
you got the resources there. I don't know how how is anybody
going to do can somebody explain to me how we could expect how
we could be expected to do like a build it yourself
security approach. Hey, we're going to let you build a bear security
approach. Brother, you're the ones with the expertise. You're
the ones with the resources. You're supposed to figure this out
at scale. That is the actual only reason you have security at
a conference like this is you're the people who are supposed
to scale this approach. No, you should not be dealing with the
creators individually. That's not what you should be doing.
Oh boy. Um I don't know what's going on with the kick chat right
now. It seems
it seems like some people dropped out. You don't have to go to
the Twitch guys, but if you do want to type and you don't want
it to be interrupted, you could try the Twitch chat. Uh it seems
like the kick chat should still be working.
Um is that coming through? Oh, that's still having issues, isn't
it? Yikes.
>> and others. Obviously, we saw one Twitch streamer yesterday,
Emu, get assaulted
>> Hello.
Who is it?
Uh, hello. What's up, M? How's it going?
>> I'm drunk and I'm high. JTO, how's that make you feel?
Your prodical son is
>> uh, I'll just not be on here to meme. Sorry. Doing actual
segments right now. Um, doing actual segments. I'll get on I'll
get back on Discord in a little bit. Love you, Mal. >> A
male fan. >> Okay, so there's the Dan Clansancy thing.
I have no idea why he hopped on here. I have no idea why he hopped
on. He should have canceled this interview. You should not be
making public statements that aren't like triple vetted to make
sure you don't seem like a reptile.
And unfortunately, I feel like there's just a lot of seeming
like a reptile right now that's going on.
It's unfortunate.
what else do we got here? I've got some other stuff I wanted
to look at. We've got some like Asminold Asmin Gold takes on
this.
Let's see here.
Wait, we have some Techone takes, some Asmin Gold takes.
Oh, hold on. We had LSF was kind of sweeping things up. I guess
the best friend clip got posted on LSF. Chloic was looking at
this earlier this morning and noticed that like in the middle
of himself viewing these things, one of these clips was removed.
>> Oh, I've still got it here on >> randomly. This
is the thing I was trying to find earlier. >> Yeah, I got
a hashtag give it back.
seeing meet and greet was pretty cool
>> That was fun. >> That's him. That is him. Why
did they take this down? That's the guy.
>> We checked these out. >> I think I'm like 99%
sure.
>> Seeing meet and greet was pretty cool
>> That was fun.
>> That's him, right? That's the That is the That is the
>> saw the homies back. >> He's on a mission. >> That's
him. That is him. Yes,
>> dude. I don't know how best friend found that clip.
>> Look, they took it down.
>> Look, unsourced allegations. I mean, okay. I I'm pretty
sure it's the guy, but like, what are people going to do? Oh,
that check shirt guy. Let's get him.
>> I don't know why this wouldn't be brought up. >> Queer.
It's unbelievable. >> Oh, I I also got to point something
out >> stupid Reddit moderation as per usual. As per usual.
>> Okay, I'm noticing uh this is going to be totally disjoint
from the MU stuff. I'm sorry to break you guys out of it, but
I I find something funny that's I think is happening right now
with Kick. I think what Kick does is I think if you don't type
after a certain amount of time, right, I think Kick stops counting
you as a viewer right now. I think they're trying out a system
like that to deal with view bots or something, right? And I think
what's happening is it's knocking people because I think the
the kick chat is like failing to register or work properly right
now. I think it's actually like making viewership drop across
the platform. So everybody I see with like usually double the
number of viewers they have because I think nobody can chat correctly
because it's like cutting out intermittently. Um I'm seeing viewership
drop off for every streamer just like massively. I think that's
happening. Just look at like everybody anybody you're used to
watching. Queen normally 150 200 viewers when he first goes to
kick 75. Uh Gunnar usually like 300 500 viewers 145.
Um I find that very funny. Okay. I just think that's very interesting
that I think that's what's going on. And I think they're sort
of you see how their anti-botting stuff would work is it must
be something like that cuz with the chat broken it seems like
people's views are just dropping super hard.
Um I find that kind of stuff interesting. I don't know if everyone
else finds that kind of stuff interesting. Kicks event right
now is cooked because it has like 2 million viewers. Oh, like
the whole platforms. Wait, there's a kick event. Wait, what do
you mean there's a kick event?
Watch now. Stake kick.
What is this?
This two million viewers is crashing the whole platform for them.
That's kind of gay. I don't like that.
Stream Fighters 4. So, they're hosting this West Cole boxing
thing. 3 million viewers. Cool. The platform doesn't work for
any of the rest of us, bro. The
Could you figure something out? This messed up, man.
2.9 million viewers. I'm sure they got a lot here, but how about
you stop [__] this up for all of us, man?
What are you doing?
Jesus. Holy. I wasn't actually watching. Jesus Christ. BBL boxing.
That's I I guess there's a cottage industry for BBL boxing. Okay,
that's kind of wild. Didn't expect that to be what was popping
off right now. All right, I'm looking around at some of the responses
here. We got a Valkyrie response. Seeing Emiry get assaulted
after Twitch banned her preferred personal bodyguard from being
there to protect her. And watching the guy walk away in the clip
is incredibly disappointing. Stay safe, everybody. Nothing but
love to you, Emmy. Wow.
How can you talk about this when there are kids? I knew I knew
Valkyrie post on Twitter. She's absolutely going to get like
blown up.
Everybody's going to be like, "Uh, have you talked about Hassan
recently? Excuse me. You're trying to reach out and tell your
friend that you're concerned about them. Um, have you thought
about Hassan recently? Have you talked about Hassan? Have you
defended Hassan? Hassan. Hassan. Hassan. Hassan.
Unlucky.
That do be how Twitter go though.
Asmin Gold had a long text take on this. And then we've got
we've got a long rap tone take on it as well.
All right, after this I'm gonna probably just go to different
random clips or or different clips of this stuff. Oh, hold on.
Before that, Amir throwing some shade over at >> two Amir
throwing some some shade at Twitch at her own cosplay show taking
place at TwitchCon. >> To my two main hosts,
>> how are you guys feeling? Have you picked a winner?
I think I know my winner. >> You already have your winner.
>> I think I have my winner. All right. >> Sorry.
I must have caught mono at my meet and greet.
That's actually way worse than I thought it would be. Holy [__]
That's actually way worse than I thought it would be. She said
she got she caught mono at her meet and greet, as in like from
the guy trying to make out with her. Yeah, that's uh that's a
pre-written line. That's pretty funny, though. Pretty funny stuff.
Who is this guy? Totally like zonked in the background. This
guy's on some Zans back here. Damn. Are you pretending that was
a good roast for Emirou? That was borderline like what a college-aged
person could describe or or throw out as a roast. So, yes, that's
amazing. Oh, um, somebody just pointed out that Ethan Klein confirmed
they were dating. Bro, everybody knew they were dating. Everyone's
known they were dating for a long time. I understand it wasn't
public. Every single person who didn't know that they were dating
before this is somebody who didn't really follow this stuff and
doesn't care. Every single person who who really hates Hassan
or really loves Hassan knew that Valkyrie and and Emiru or sorry,
Valkyrie and Hassan were dating. Not Valkyrie and Emiru. Yeah.
Okay.
All right. Moving from there, we're going to read these two posts.
Okay. This is the big long Asminold post, right? Asmin was right.
Asmin Gold urges women to avoid TwitchCon 2025. criticizes Twitch
CEO over safety concerns. Asigold warns women not to attend TwitchCon
after Valkyrie and Cutie Cinderella drop out, citing safety fears.
All right.
Uh, and Asigold actually goes a little into depth on this post
is from yesterday. I think 10 hours ago, actually, this morning,
this might be a bit longer post. Sorry. To expand on this statement,
the reason I said this actually had nothing to do with Charlie
Kirk or any other civil unrest this year. Oh, I said this actually
had nothing to do with that. Well, of course, it's an agitating
variable. It wasn't the reason. Last year at TwitchCon, NMP Lull
and Wake Wilder were insulted live and on camera. Twitch made
no statement and just pret and pretended like this didn't happen.
That type of behavior is disgusting, wrong, and has no place
in civilized society. Anyone with a brain knew that if this had
happened to a female creator at the time, Twitch's response would
have been completely different. Anyone without a brain had that
proven last night. Um,
oh man, there's a thing going on with DBR there. I'm I do think
it was wrong what DBR did, but there was a thing with Nick. Like
DBR was playing gay chicken with Nick right off the bat. And
Nick was like kind of leaning back into it instead of just going
like, "You're a weirdo. Leave me alone." And and he doesn't he
shouldn't have to do that, right? But I think that's what led
DBR to escalate to get a reaction and then it popped off that
way. Um, this Nick's not at fault, but I'm telling you that DBR
was doing something and I think Nick naturally as a streamer
didn't want to like let him win and it turned into what it turned
into, which is really, you know, unfortunate for him. Uh, anyway,
continuing on, to me, this proved an undeniable cynical reality.
Twitch doesn't care about assault. They care about the optics
of assault. If they had cared, they would have approached it
with men in the same way. This proves their motives are driven
by optics rather than principle.
Under that reasoning, it could be assumed that Twitch would allow
the same thing to occur again this year. Why wouldn't they? They
got away with it last year. That this is what uh this is what
my true reasoning was behind what I said. Even now, Twitch refuses
to apologize to Emiru or even name her inocu name her innocuous
to the uninitiated but obvious to the informed.
They're refusing to apologize because it could be used against
them in a lawsuit. They're refusing to name her to avoid boosting
SEO, search engine optimization, connecting the company to this
event, and to not further spread her name in the hopes that it
will minimize the controversy. Um, Dan Clansancy literally named
her. Um, maybe the Twitch team didn't. I do think there would
be like if it wasn't broadly uh publicized,
like couldn't this just have been thrown back at them in the
exact same way? Couldn't this have been thrown back at them as,
"Oh, Emir wanted this kept quiet and Twitch publicized that Emir
was assaulted," leading to a bunch of people googling this.
Couldn't you have just gone back at them in like this a similar
way
if they had
published like the name and then Dan Clansancy said her name?
So,
uh, in front of everyone, they put optics over principle and
insult your intelligence by assuming you're too stupid to see
it. Actions speak louder than words, and what people avoid saying
often reveals their true intent. I apologize that sometimes when
I speak on issues that I do so in such a brash and offensive
tone that it polarizes people against me. When things like this
happen, it makes me think about that a lot. Could I have made
a bigger difference if I was less of an? Maybe.
Maybe if people didn't hate me, they would have listened. Another
Cassandra problem. Okay.
Yet again, stay safe, trust your instincts, and believe what
you see and not what you hear. Would I be more Oh, this person
got blown up. I don't know who this is. Is this a big creator
or something? It's not. Would I be more credible if I behaved
in a credible manner? The answer is yes. And that's why I used
to follow years ago. Return to those days. 98 comments, 28 26
likes. This person going to get blown the up.
Okay. Techone statement here. Okay. I need to remind everyone
of something important. This happened to Emmy. [__]
Emmy, the largest female streamer on the planet, generating Twitch
millions of dollars every month. Her public meet and greet had
a defense force of one guy that couldn't even do his job. The
guy Emir paid, by the way, it gets worse.
This is only what we prevented from continuing. Or this is only
what we prevented from continuing. Now, I'm not going to lie.
Emmy is strong as individual is a is a strongest individual and
has dealt with a lot over the years. This will just add to the
list of she shouldn't have had to go through and somehow she'll
tank it and keep a smile on for her viewers.
The man could have stabbed her. No one should be dropping their
guard because the worst didn't happen. It's horrifying because
it could have happened. Arena Zeritzka comes to
there's no way this guy is real. This isn't a real person. This
straight up This straight up is not a real person. Okay. Holy
[__] Hold on. I just knocked my soundboard over.
This isn't a real person. Arena Zeritzka. You're bringing up
Arena Zeritzka now.
This is Arena Zeritzka for gamer virgins. Waking them up. Okay.
Arena Zerutka woke a lot of people up apparently to some some
race realism arguments. Some some absolute like
some absolute premier
oh what would you call it? Not virtue signaling although also
virtue signaling. It's like one of those things. It's like how
the news gets you invested in stuff. This could happen to you.
People are being killed now randomly on trains, right?
Oh boy.
Aruneritzka comes to mind for how quick tragedy can strike. This
man casually walked up and forced himself on her. People, you
are not angry enough about this. Dan Clansancy and Twitch need
to be held accountable.
Sunday, October 19th, Q&A with Dan Clancy, Brown v. Board
of Education got revisited. That's true.
Oh god. Good thing it's a white guy who assaulted her. Oh, I
said this um I was watching Queen's stream. I said if it was
an Indian guy who assaulted her, we'd have boots on the ground
in Mumbai right now. Okay. Unironically, there would be American
boots on the ground in Mumbai if a brown person had assaulted
Emiru. Okay, I'm just saying it how it is. We all know that's
true. Thank god Neon didn't do what this guy did cuz it would
be over for India. All right,
luckily this just remains Emy's personal 911 instead of 911 2
electric bugaloo. Okay, good reason, says Nemo. Shut up. Okay,
hold on. Hold on. We've got finally finally we've got a contrarian
take. Okay, I didn't think anybody was strong enough to do it.
Who is the guy standing up for the side of Well, it doesn't seem
that bad.
It's uh it's the guy who stands up on that side very often. Okay.
Very often, it's Veto. It's Veto.
So, Veto is responding to the tech tone, the red tone statement.
Okay. Some weirdo tried to hug her and was immediately stopped
by security. How much drama can you possibly milk out of this
nothing story?
man. Oh, he doesn't you don't think he knows who Techto? He has
to know who Tectton is.
>> he doesn't know doesn't know anything about Rape Tone.
Okay, well, this is just hilarious to me in that like
I think I think stuff is being blown out of proportion for where
it is in reality, but oh my goodness, this is this is not something
people are prepared to hear next day, okay? Ever.
Beto's out here on September 12th being like, "Guys, I think
we should cool it with the with the Islamophobia." Okay, the
Islamophobia is really disgusting right now. It's like, "Yeah,
that's probably true, but uh you need to chill, bro. You can't
you can't be saying that. All right, you can't get away with
saying that right now. You're not in the environment where that's
an okay thing to say. That's not good. That's not going to work
out. How much money could he milk out of this with his nothing
comic?" Dude, apparently Warp Thing, I don't know if you know
this, apparently Veto's comic was really good. Apparently, a
bunch of people watched that or read that comic and thought it
was awesome.
Like comic readers, like people who actually like comics read
that comic and were like, "Oh, this is this is base. This is
super cool." Yeah, pretty good bait tweet, though. I just moved
Sorry, I just moved my browser over because I was going to tweet.
Honestly, just respect how hard this is going to catch this bait
is going to catch people. Yeah, that's basically it. Uh, hold
on. Grab that tweet real quick. I just I just think like he's
going to so many people are going to freak the out on Veto again.
All right. Again and again and again. Is Emiru white? Can Teto
work it into his White Lives Matter thing? Uh, yeah. She She
is, isn't she? She's Is she wian or is she just white?
I think she's like Yeah, she's half white, half Asian. Okay.
Okay. She's she's all right. People who like his comic equals
the movies liked by Yms. H. Okay. I don't know if that's I don't
know if that makes any sense to me, that comment, but okay. I'll
throw that in the kick chat. I'll throw that in the Twitch chat.
All right, I'm looking to stick on the Emmy topic because I know
there's going to be a bunch of stuff from today that's gone out,
but I have to go find some. So, give me a second. I just I've
got like some random YouTube com uh clips. Uh hold on. I'll I'll
pull up this one thing Riyle pulled up because it it did look
very funny. Okay,
hold on. Ry Riyle sent me a video. I think Chud pulled up on
his stream like I think Chud just searched and found this guy.
Okay, I think judges searched and found this guy and oh wait,
I missed it. Hold on. Dan Clansancy had another statement on
this today first and then we'll go through and watch the funny
Amiru video. Um there's one question that has been coming up
on social media um just in terms of safety and security um at
TwitchCon in light of recent events. So I want to be very clear,
we take security at our events like TwitchCon extremely seriously.
Um every year we build on successful approach to TwitchCon s
uh stop talking about like I I he just doesn't understand at
all like I don't know these people there's like I think there's
a second generation gap happening okay I think there are a lot
of people who got tech jobs because they sort of they grew up
with tech they understood it quite a bit and they got tech jobs
and then those people further have never been like fully engrossed
in this tech sphere at all or sorry in this um social media sphere
in a way where they can like see what's going to happen like
like Dan Clancy should have a good idea of where Asminold's going
to go with the NMP and Wake Wilder assault. He should have a
good idea of that and he should not be leaning into guys. We
have a successful approach from years past. Isn't this from like
a month ago? Uh I don't know when it's from, but I think um I
think again I knew we knew about the assaults that happened at
the previous TwitchCon. We knew people were upset because of
the previous TwitchCon. The response to people being upset about
bad things happening is not to say we're the best and sometimes
bad things happen. That's not what customers want to hear from
you. Okay? And in this case, these streamers are Dan Clancy's
customer. So, it's now being resurfaced again to go, look, he's
he's bragging about how great they are at stuff,
And it just it's not going to work. It's going to be used against
you every single time. >> Safety and security, particularly
as we become aware of new or emerging um security or safety challenges.
So, we have teams focused on this year round um
>> uh Veto already responded to me. Hold on. Did he quote
tweet or I can't tell if Veto quote tweeted or if he um he replied.
People are talking about it like somebody threw acid on her.
They are. Veto doesn't understand. Veto doesn't get it. Okay.
Dan Clansancy celebrated. Twitch must fall. Okay. A million A
million concurrent viewers must go. All right. Must I was going
to say
nothing. But listen, the site has to take a hit for this. Okay.
Veto doesn't understand. Veto is totally on Twitter. Veto probably
has the closer to reality take than the one I'm performatively
putting on. That's not even really that's barely above what Tech's
doing.
Like probably this is like a thing that could happen, but you
one nobody's going to like when you say it right after the actual
bad thing happens, right? And two
and two I still you still don't want to go in the victim blaming
or or like you know the not caring side of it. You probably want
to stay silent if you're just in the like, oh, you had something
bad happen to you. Not that big a deal. You probably just want
to you probably just want to not say it, you know, keep that
to yourself if you don't want people to be mad. But sometimes
maybe Veto just wants to be mad, okay? Or wants people to be
mad at him. Okay.
All right. I think there's some stuff on the O feed. O is O is
farming this up like a champ right now. All right.
Majorly farming this. Where's the Hassan response?
I'm being told we have a Hassan response to O directly. Asan
accuses me of blasting and talking about him and not going uh
not going out in public. Also calls out Techone, LSF and other
content creators, drama farmers, places like LSF, that soccer
account yeet that has become the LSF of Twitter. Dictone and
otherwise. >> Why does he call him Dick Tone instead >> saying
I don't really want to go to TwitchCon? Because I don't feel
safe. >> And everyone was saying that they were stupid
or overreact. Not everyone, but a lot of people. >> Yes,
a lot of were saying that. It was other content creators that
were saying that.
It was other content creators that were talking [__]
too. Yeah.
Content creators and drama farmers,
places like LSF,
places like uh that that stalker account that has now become
like the LSF of Twitter. Ye. So many of these
blasted >> Wait, they did kind of blast him for not wanting
to go in public, right? Yeah, they did. I I would say they did
kind of blast him. Now, as Migle is going to say, "No, no, no.
It's just Tocon specifically. It has nothing to do with Charlie
Kirk, but I think a lot of content creators were worried about
the Charlie Kirk thing." Yeah, for sure. >> Blasted Cutie.
Yeah. Tone. That's another one.
Blasted Cutie. Blasted Pokey. Blasted Ray. I don't
do you guys think like in my head it's incredibly stupid on Hassan's
part to go and complain about how bad things are for him when
Amir is responding to being assaulted, right? Or you know assaulted
in some way. Maybe I don't know if it converts to because the
guy like smooched his lips necessarily.
Um but assaulted in any case put in an incredibly uncomfortable
position. I don't know if Hassan can't tell that it looks really
bad to make that about him,
but or if he if he knows that and he's willing to just like signal
out to his fan base that like, oh, you should blame other people
for this. You should know that I'm like more correct over this,
right? I just I think it's like a Yeah, it's really bad timing.
Um,
yeah. I don't know. Had that woman size him up that one time.
She did indeed.
I I just can't tell if he doesn't Does he just not understand?
Does he not get it at all or or is he is this something intentional?
Like he understands it totally and he it's intentional and he
wants to keep doing it. I I literally can't tell. I'm I'm genuinely
curious like about what he's trying to do here.
Hassan hasn't had that character development yet. I don't know
if we can even say he's making it about himself if we only see
the 60-second clip. Porter Beller, it seems like you're telling
me you want to watch a full Hassan baud right now. And I may
have just the thing. Do we watch the full Hassan VOD here? Do
we go and see if if he's being clipped out of context with some
of these things? I actually don't even know if I'd rather watch
this one or the one where he had his like black pill rant cuz
his black pill rant was like very long, right? And I got the
sense there that that might not have been the whole story. Give
me a second. I'm looking for this timestamp. I had a time stamp
for Assan's VOD right here. Okay. Have you He's like literally
had people re rewatch his entire VOD library like over, you know,
a period of two weeks. So, I totally understand what he's talking
about. He sees it as a problem. I think it's inappropriate to
shoehorn that into the Emmy discussion because it feels quite
disconnected. >> I don't want this.
I hope this the one good thing that comes out of this is that
people actually really check themselves and really reconsider
what kind of spaces that they occupy and really reconsider how
they beha behave on the internet cuz nobody deserves this kind
of uh nobody deserves this
>> experience at all. No one. It's It's so so unacceptable
because I know that
I know that for a lot of people >> I'm trying to think
of if he genuinely thinks these are connected. He might genuinely
think that that level of of of obsession turns into the same
thing. I do believe when you have that like romantic or or element
to your content in a way that you don't otherwise like open up.
Like people don't primarily tune into Hassan. It's a nice secondary
thing, but they don't primarily tune into Hassan to imagine they
have a relationship with him. Okay. There is probably some people
who do that, but it's smaller.
I do not believe there's a large primary community with like
someone like Emiru who's doing this kind of who's who's doing
something outside of that.
And it's just a higher proclivity chance of this happening. And
it's way different than the LCA stuff. >> They look at
this and they go, "Whatever, she's rich." It's like, "Okay, dude.
It's insane. You are just trying to justify that kind of behavior.
or justify the kind of like cyberstalker behavior if you ever
say something like >> When you have people contact animal
control to control to free kaya, it makes sense. It doesn't make
sense. Sorry, you're you're failing to understand how I'm describing
where this intersects with like his life, right? I totally understand
that Hassan has people who are like stalking him and he feels
extremely disturbed by this, like how every element of his life
is under a microscope. I understand that. I'm empathetic to that.
I understand how that's crossed into real life with people trying
to report him possibly like confronting him in real life over
over Kaio. Like I understand how that could all cross over. I'm
saying that's fundamentally a totally different issue than what
led to this real life confrontation with Emirou in such a way
that it feels weird for him to connect it to Emiru because it
feels like a totally different problem.
So while I am while I could say I'm empathetic to Hassan's feelings
that like he's feeling like a parasocialness ruining his life
in a way that he feels similarly uh just happened. and Emiru.
I think the causes are so separated, they're so different, they're
so distinct that putting them together and trying to present
them as the same issue is kind of goofy. Like kind of how when
we get Twitch called into Congress, right,
when when Twitch gets called into Congress because of the Tyler
Robinson shooting and no, Twitch has nothing to do with it, right?
It's sort of shoehorned because it's a part of another issue
and people are trying to present it as like a thing that's connected.
I'll call I'll call it out there. I'll call it out here. >> Anyway,
okay. All right, we're getting to the next clip coming up here.
We're looking. We're looking. >> This should be a moment
of self-reflection. I see people that say that she is the reason
why that fan did what uh did that because that's how she built
the community. No thoughts. Yeah,
I mean, there is an element to that. I don't think she can be
blamed for it. I think you can monetize that kind of content.
Like there's a there's a clear demand for that kind of content,
right? I don't have a problem with somebody filling that content
demand. I do think like security concerns change when you do
that kind of content, when you build those kinds of relationships.
But I think she's broadly aware of that. I don't think she was
unaware of that. I think she had security there. She paid. She
did everything she needed to do to make sure that didn't happen,
right? She went to a con that promised her they'd take care of
security. She hired her own private security to be there. She
did everything she could to prevent that from happening. She
didn't up somehow and like build a community where that could
happen and then not take any steps to prevent it from happening.
So that whole like Emir might be at fault here kind of goes away
when she takes explicit steps to make sure that that kind of
[__] doesn't happen. >> Exactly. Luckily, there
hasn't been
luckily there hasn't been that big of a push back of this sort
that I have seen in public because everyone is like uh everyone
is is very frustrated right now about what happened. But if you
think it is a crazy thing to say for the record, yes, it is a
crazy thing to say, but you need to understand something. Okay?
While it is a crazy thing to say, people do say it. Okay? It's
a crazy thing to say and people do say it.
>> Okay? which 100% dropped the ball. The setup of this
was cooked, man. It was really cooked. >> We went over
it uh last night, today. Totally cooked. Slaughtery killer. Thank
you for the 100 kicks, buddy. Anyway, appreciate it. Okay, let's
go, man. >> It's the locking uh victim blame
>> what are we looking for? I'm looking for the guy just
walked out like it's nothing. That's crazy. >> The other
clip. >> So, when he actually when he actually watches
the Emmy video is when he >> walked out of the >> makes
like the comments. That's the guy. >> He just walked out
of the >> dude. Best friend kick. I messaged this guy today
and was just like, "Oh man, I'm really glad this picked up for
you." Cuz what I see happen to him, he started watermarking his
now, right? I see him get scooped by like massive accounts sometimes
and they don't even shout him out. I lose my mind cuz I when
I was like doing more of the when I was focusing more on tweeting,
getting like clips out very early. Uh I I retweeted this guy
and I used like his stories on his timeline to go and like build
stories for my stream. And then I would watch him like not get
sourced at all by other people. It's it's such So he started
watermark marking. He started watermarking stuff. All of his
all of his hard work is being rewarded. Let's go. Did you ask
best friend how he found it? I asked him. He hasn't responded
to me. I don't know if he will respond or not. I don't know if
he's like super busy right now. >> Front gates after after
doing that. That is crazy. Look.
>> Even my wife argued that I should mess this behavior.
I had to argue the lack of accessible mental health benefits
of healthcare is a bigger issue.
Dude, what? Hold on. I have to get him to go stop with that.
Hold on. Hold on.
Okay, don't turn Don't turn this into a systemic issue. Okay,
what the [__] is this? Even my wife argued that IRL
streaming invites this behavior. It absolutely does. It's why
they know as IRL streamers, they shouldn't be broadcasting the
location directly. They shouldn't be saying, "Here's where I'm
going. Here's the location where I'm going." Right? There's a
whole art to this. I had to argue that the lack of accessible
mental health care benefits and healthcare is a bigger issue.
I mean, it is a bigger issue, but it is so big that it's hard
to tie it to this issue.
I'm sorry, people being mentally ill does probably lead to this,
but even places with better mental health care would probably
still have this kind of thing happen. It's just what happens
when super famous people are broadcasting their location 24/7.
Even my wife argued that I should measure. I had to argue that
the lack of accessible mental health benefits of healthcare is
a bigger issue. Yeah, dude. No, that's that's insane. That is
insane.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Hold on. Oh, does Assan
have the proper Did Assan just go, "Brother, you are ill. That's
so up. That guy's day is ruined." Hey, I debated my wife on this
and I said it was a systemic issue. Brother, that's wrong. What
are you doing? Oh, that's brutal. It's never been a moreover
for that guy. >> Amber gets attacked at Twitchcon and there
are still chatters in here trying to give it back.
>> So,
seeing meet and greet was pretty cool though. Yeah, he's right
there.
>> There is no real method of stopping this. We have no
legislation. We have no no uh methods mechanisms of apprehension.
It's also not really taken seriously as well is really >> uh
this is definitely taken seriously. Um but I again I can't help
but think that he's talking about his current situation and letting
that bleed into his content or at least it's like pressing on
the back of his like brain in a way that it's informing his takes.
You know what I'm saying? Like it doesn't feel like these are
takes free of bias, free of the bias of the the situation he's
gone through with Ka over the past two weeks. >> Reallyed
up
like it's one thing to just say it's one thing to just say, "Oh,
well, you know, it is what it is. This is bad."
But but like there is an environment there is a culture on the
>> Yeah, it this is what it is. >> That has
uh that has tried to justify this kind of over and over again.
I I'll give him a pass on this because I do think I know a lot
of people don't care. They only care about Kaia. I do think the
Kaya stuff has been like uniquely
crazy to me and like popular in a way that feels kind of [__]
up. Like I I could go like, "Oh, I I understand why you would
be [__] up about that even if you were at fault."
Right? It's not absolving him of anything he might have done
wrong there. It's just me going like, I understand why this would
invade almost every part of your thinking because you've been
under like a a negative PR campaign the likes of which the internet
rarely sees if ever. I'd say there's probably been a lot of actual
on the internet who haven't had this level of negative PR campaign
run against them. So I I get where he's coming from how this
is like making him biased, but it's we don't have to buy
there is a permission structure that we are supposed to maintain
um as a mechanism of like social enforcement and I feel like
the more vicious we become, the more ruthless we become online,
the more people find ways of justifying this kind of behavior.
I cannot believe that this person did not actually get
uh I cannot believe that this person did not actually uh immediately
get apprehended by law
I feel like at some point, >> how are you not arrested?
How do you get to walk out of the >> Dude, they you could
tell their security approach is like very Silicon Valley though,
right? Like their Silicon their security approach is basically
like, "Sir, please do not cross this. Please do not cross this
uh barrier here. This like rope barrier. Okay, this rope barrier,
it means everything. That that's what protects our society."
And then the dude like steps over the rope barrier and they have
no idea what to do. It's now a 6'5 260lb dude standing like towering
over this like 5'3 100 lb security girl. It's like oh well the
the velvet rope didn't work guys. What are we what what what
else were we supposed to do? We had the top technologies. Did
you see how much velvet rope we had between all these people?
How could he get through?
Like you do this, you do this to when you do this to anyone,
let alone like a famous person on camera, but just like anyone
in general, you should be arrested. And I guess that
>> Sure, I could see it. >> That I guess also
uh uh is is another
that also is another problem with law enforcement as well. They're
just like very bad at at >> I will just be
>> Oh, one second.
>> $3 guy will find another remy route. Okay. All right.
Um Hassan coming out as pro cop. Maybe not a legal expert, but
I'd see uh but if they see a felony happen in front of them,
can't they detain them until the cops show up? I think there's
like very it's very weird how that works, Matt. Depending on
So,
I'm thinking of
when we watch the organized retail theft stuff. I know stores
told managers literally do not interrupt people trying to steal.
You cannot do that. uh our insurance will will be liable. We
will be in trouble if you like try to interrupt this, right?
Was that a felony? We don't know that it was a felony. So, I'm
trying to think of like in my head, how much concern is there
about liability and they don't even want people who have the
proclivity to tackle somebody because they don't want to be held
liable for that, right? And how does that intersect with keeping
people safe? So, it's possible that they have the right to detain
them or don't have the right to detain them, but it's possible
they they make a miscalculation in whether or not they have the
right to detain somebody. Maybe they're held liable. Maybe they,
you know, can't book an event a venue after that or maybe they
get sued after that. Right?
So, I'm looking at this and I'm I'm personally sitting here being
like, well, I can understand how this works in other cases with
security. I don't know how they'd interpret it here or how they'd
handle it, but it seems like it could be very similar where you
don't you physically restraining somebody is actually quite difficult
to do. Now, I don't even think that gets Twitch off the hook
here cuz I'm not sure anybody attempted to just ask this guy
to remain there or went to go and like follow him. I think they
basically just let the guy walk. Nobody was able to react. Nobody
saw what happened and he just walked
and they couldn't coordinate fast enough to figure out like,
"Oh, he went this way. We need to cut him off at the
which is pretty crazy. >> Yeah. You would be arrested for
doing this to a mall Santa. Exactly. Anyway, >> um
again it would depend like I think the issue is the issue here
is that somehow nobody saw the assault. Now I don't believe that
actually when when they say I think Emiru was saying even that
they didn't see the assault happen. There has to be a security
guard who saw the assault.
>> She's literally watching. I literally see her looking
at the assault happening. I can see the yellow vest, the high
viz vest. I see the person looking. There is at least one person
who should think, "Oh, I have to go detain this guy." Now, again,
how much of her reasoning here is, well, I'm just a tiny person.
I can't go stop that guy.
That lady isn't security. I thought the yellow high viz
uh people were security. Everybody's described the yellow shirted
people as security. Is this lady also not security? Then where
is Twitch security here?
You're saying that's not security, but just event staff. So,
there's no security anywhere near this is what I'm hearing. Now,
I do think somebody should be following this guy. I'm shocked.
I'm shocked humans didn't do anything. This seems bizarre to
me. Did you watch Yeah, we watch Emiru's take. We We covered
all of this stuff already. Taco Canada, welcome to the stream.
Uh, if you haven't caught any of this stuff, it'll be in the
VOD or whatever. We watch all of Amiru's statements. We've watched
Dan Clancy's interview with Taylor Lens. Dan Clansy's given horrible
answers on this. We're now catching up. We're watching the Hassan
take because O has been going back and forth with Hassan on Twitter,
right? And Hassan's trying to make a point out of this that I
think is a little a little bad. So, we're we're covering his
uh his take here.
People are so desensitized to reality that they thought it was
all part of the show. I don't think so. Um that's possible, Jake
event, that we're underestimating just like the bystander effect
and and how it was like not clear what happened or if the guy
did anything wrong. Although, apparently Emiru is screaming.
So, if she's like shrieking at the top of her lungs, it's hard
to believe that somebody didn't think it was a problem. >> Gross.
All right, here's Twitch's statement on it. The safety and security
of all those attending TwitchCon is our highest priority. The
behavior displayed by the individual involved in the incident
yesterday involving a high-profile streamer was completely unacceptable
and deeply upsetting. In line with existing TwitchCon security
protocols, law enforcement and event security were on-site and
responded to the incident. We immediately blocked this individual
from returning to TwitchCon premises and they are banned indefinitely
from Twitch, both online and in person events. We are coordinating
with the impacted creators team and per our standard protocols.
>> Okay, I don't want to go too much further through the
Hassan stuff. I do want to see his response and his uh his referencing
of a here which >> unimaginable uh ineptitude
unimaginable negligence like misogyny or not, if your job is
to provide security for your >> I just don't get why you
wouldn't that guy up or follow him once you realize. I don't
think most people's I now I'm shocked Emmy's fans didn't do it,
but I don't think most people's proclivity when seeing like something
happen like that is to go commit a felony
probably. >> Regardless of your misogyny, you're like,
"Okay, we need to make sure that these streamers are still protected."
Drama Alert followers were saying they were staged. Yes, because
they're some of the dumbest ass on the planet. >> I kind
of just go into like lock in mode. I'm like, "Okay, I need to
just lock in and like get through this." Oh yeah, I was talking
about like as far as her being like, >> "Yeah, I'm desensitized
to this." It's because she deals with this all the >> We'll
worry about it later. So that that's how I was able to finish
my meet and greet
me. I would have been crying different for going back out there
and like I said, I was going back out there and having to apologize
if people was there. I didn't have this opinion like would this
>> We're looking for 9840 on these subs here.
I've said it like five
that someone was filming and decided to because if not, you know
what I would be doing today? I would be so stressed being like,
"Okay,
do I have to disrupt
my stuff that I have planned
to announce that this thing happened to me and let people know
that it could happen to them."
So, thank God for that guy. Like, thank you so much for doing
that. Um,
I would just encourage everyone just to stand the >> Why
is he always eating? Does he ever stop eating? He eats at the
same times every day, much like me. >> Proof you're a husband
making content from this liberal.
>> Okay, that's funny. That's very funny. Rage bait, isn't
it, bro? The people who are like, "Hey, you're covering people's
public statements on your stream." Uh, don't you have any respect?
I I assume she went live and talked about this cuz she wanted
people to hear her voice and like echo like review that or respond
to it in some way. No, I got to be an Asmin Gold viewer. No,
that's I don't know, man. I don't think so.
No, that's definitely not an Asmin Gold >> You mean addressing
a issue? >> Look at the comments over years >> that
took place that I've talked about quite a bit and warned about
quite a bit >> happening to someone who I know personally.
You okay? >> I don't >> [__] up.
Stand up for yourself. Stand up for other people. Cuz if you
don't
saying I don't really >> saying that >> I don't feel
safe and >> or talking too >> stupid or overreacting.
>> This has to be it. This has to be it right here. >> Yes.
A lot of were saying that. It was other content creators that
were saying
>> It was other content creators that were talking [__]
too. Yeah.
Content creators and drama farmers.
Places like LSF,
places like uh that that stalker account that has now become
like the LSF of Twitter. Ye.
So many of these
blasted >> Oh, about the Charlie Kirk thing, right?
>> Blasted Cutie. >> Yeah, that's another one.
Blasted Cutie. Blasted Pokey. Blasted >> I thought they
were virtue signaling over the kick thing that likely wasn't
going to happen again. I kind of figured like to me most creators
didn't need like a more security or something different. They
just need to be informed of like I maybe security should keep
an eye out for people who are going to be agitators, right, in
some way. But for the Emmy thing, I just assume they would have
like security around these people in the same way that again
an idol in like a Asian country would have security around them
or like public events like this, a public meet and greet.
portion of people were saying that and Twitch's response to that
was to be like, "Oh, don't worry everyone else. Uh, we up security.
I should have listened to them." Especially because I mean, a
lot of people know stuff like this has happened to me in the
past and I just keep going. Like, I'm I'm the kind of person
that's like, "You know what? I'm not going to >> like I
Here's the thing. I don't think Hassan's totally making it about
himself in a way that's like unexpected or something." But I
think I think there's just a he he's always done this before,
right? He's somebody who believed that like the obsessive communities
would lead to somebody hurting him in real life. And there is
some bleed over there. Again, for me with Hassan, it's a different
kind of community that is obsessed with him. It's a different
kind of approach that doesn't lead to what happened to Emiru
and vice versa. Right. Like DG, as much as we joke, I don't think
DG is obsessed with Assan because they're like obsessed.
Yes. And likewise, I don't think um the Emmy people would be
like obsessed with Emirou in a way where they're trying to prove
her wrong on her political takes. It's just like a very separated
different problem.
Yeah, I just don't think so. I I know I said I said I'm I'm understanding
Hubble joke. Okay.
But it's not the same thing. It's like thinking he's evil like
being brainwashed into thinking he's like the end of the West.
let a person or a thing ruin my life or like what's going on
for me. You know what I mean? [__] it. We've
So I was like, I'm going to go anyway. >> So I don't even
I don't even think that that comment right there. He just basically
complained about stopping. >> So thanks [__]
God in >> addressing a issue that's been making content
from this liberal. >> Oh, I went back too far. Hold on.
>> Portion of people were saying that and Twitch's response
to
>> Oh, I went too far. Twitch com because I don't feel
safe. >> This is it right here. >> Talking too cuz
if you don't look what I just want to watch >> issue that
took place >> in the middle of this just to make sure I
listen >> I've talked about quite a bit. >> I think
it's weird to bring up a there >> warned about quite a
bit.
>> Happening to someone who I know
>> Okay. So he says he's warned about this.
>> You okay? >> [__] up.
Stand up for yourself.
To me, this is like, okay, here's like an example. Here's like
a metaphor for what Hassan's doing. Hassan says
Thor's up in the clouds and he's banging on his hammer and Thor
hates trees. That means if you hide under that tree, you're going
to get hurt during the thunderstorm, right? And somebody hides
under the tree and then they get hurt during the thunderstorm.
All right? Because lightning strikes the tree and it falls down
and hits them and they get hurt, right? And Han goes, "See, I
was right. I was right." And it's like, okay, well, you were
kind of right and you were right about the the dangers presented
there in a way, but you didn't identify like the causes. So to
go like listen to me about the causes and my ability to identify
them. Well, no, you kind of just have a superstition here. You
don't really understand what's happening, right? Something happened
that to that happened to go along with what you're saying, but
it it's for a very different reason. And so when you're attributing
it to like yourself, you're going, "Oh, because you know, you're
just mad because I'm correct about this." And all of these other
accounts made fun of me for saying that like I was concerned.
Which I think is a valid point again in a different direction
that like he had every right to be concerned after the Charlie
Kirk thing, but not for the same reason Emu should be. >> Stand
up for other people. So >> cuz if you don't, look what
happens. which is crazy because
I saw Valkyrie, I saw Pokey, I saw Hassan, I saw Cutie saying,
"I don't really want to go to TwitchCon because I don't feel
safe." And everyone was saying that they were stupid or overreact.
Not everyone, but a lot of people. >> So, this is the one.
Hold on. This is the one I had to watch it again cuz I wasn't
paying attention to what Emir was saying there, but Emir's literally
So, this can't be one of those like self-obsessed moments cuz
he does just go, "Yeah, people did get mad at me. All these apps
got mad at me for saying this. So Emir is going, "Oh, Hassan
agrees with me." And Hassan's going, "Yeah." And all of these
people didn't agree with us, Emmy.
Okay, I got it. I think the connective tissue is the Twitch event
having bad security. Um,
>> no, cuz cuz nothing Hassan's complained about is issues
from Twitch security. All of the things Hassan's complaining
about with regards to things that happened to him are not things
that except I guess Well, no, they're not things that happened
at like a Twitch event. So, I guess Darius technically pressed
Frogan outside of TwitchCon where there wouldn't be Twitch security,
but that's the only one thing he's referenced that even remotely
came close to Twitch for his own situation. So, again, I I don't
think he's informing this based on Twitch having bad
>> A lot of were saying that it was other content creators
that were saying that.
It was other content creators that were talking, too. Yeah.
Content. Oh, also also real quick, we're going to move on from
this now. I think we've gotten everything we need to out of this
VOD. All right, real quick. I want you guys to go and
Raph was shoved outside by some kick streamer. Was Raph with
Frogan? Cuz if Raph was just with Frogan, she's he was probably
pushed by Darius. Um, but I think he grabbed something from Darius
first. So, I want to move on. I think this one you can't call
him obsessed as much, but I'm I'm good to move on to some other
stuff here, some other adjacent commentary, cuz I was going to
look. I think there's some Asold stuff from today on on ox.
We watch the full the Robnor full crash out. We can watch some
of the Robnor stuff, but I'm going to do the litter box stuff
first.
So, Kurioa, we need a long stream today so we can get through
all the content. Okay, guys, if you want a long stream, if you
want to help contribute to the content going hard, if you want
to commit to it going longer today, longer and harder and uncut.
All right, I need you to dig deep into your hearts and your wallets
and throw a couple bucks my way. All right, we've got I think
uh is this eight subs? Eight subs left to get another two hours
on the stream. We got 27 minutes left. We're eight subs away
from another two hours. All right,
loner cr. No, it's not a loner box crash out. Matt Nelt. Um Loner
Box had some people on his stream, including Dan Saltman and
uh one member of like sort of this sort of leftwing community.
Um, and they were talking about doxing communities and what what
it means to be a doxing community. Possibly some of like Dan's
lies and stuff. We'll take a we'll take a look at it. All right,
we'll take a look at it. Should be interesting creators. >> But
we're going to need more time on the stream because I think I've
got some more Asmin Gold content to do on this front and I'm
going to farm this as much as I humanly can, as much as humanly
possible. Uh, oh, we watched this one. I don't know if I've got
other Asmin Gold content. I thought I had more Asmin Gold stuff.
I got no other Asmin Gold stuff. There's no way. He did a full
stream and he's not even saying crazy.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Hold on. Marmadude, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it. Wait, what?
Asminold hints that whatever Emmy's got cooking up next will
make TwitchCon look like an appetizer.
>> He's right, by the way. Okay,
>> what could this possibly be vague posting at? If you
think today was bad, just wait. I don't know what they could
possibly be. Oh,
wait. I have a good idea. I bet you there's a bunch of people
reaching out to TechOne or Asmin Gold and saying, "You guys are
right. I was insulted at TwitchCon in like 2019 and they didn't
do anything about it." How much you want to bet that that's what
it's going to be? A bunch of people coming up with new stories.
And
um Emmy said when she came home she was going to talk about something.
Oh, we'll see. Only two things get Asmin Gold and Techone this
excited. One is the potential downfall of Miskf, which Emmy could
obviously contribute to. And two is the potential downfall of
Twitch itself, which again Emmy could contribute to. So, we'll
see how it goes. All right, I think we're I think we're done
with the Emmy stuff. I haven't seen other MU Oh, wait, wait,
wait, no, no, no, no. I've lied to you. I've lied to you. There's
just one other goofy thing that apparent that I got thrown a
link to.
Just one more goofy video
to throw in the pile. Okay. About Emirou. Hold on. It's not that
one. It's this one. No, hold on. Where is it? Where is it? Where
is it? Where is it? Do I not have this anymore? Oh, I will probably
I need to go find this. Hold on. Sometimes when people link stuff,
I just like lose in the in the list of links like something.
And I don't know if I saved this video. So, I have to go find
it really quickly. Give me a second.
I messed it up.
So, apparently, Chad, check this out and it was just kind of
funny. I might I might watch this for like a minute. Okay, this
guy posted this last night on YouTube and apparently it was showing
up pretty high in terms of the YouTube search stuff and I just
thought it was funny. It was like people were so outraged about
the Emmy thing and they all looked exactly how you think. The
people who would instantly get the Emmy news and make a tailored
video about it to put up on YouTube, they all were like the exact
person you would think. Okay. >> I got my crappy camera
working too once.
>> I fight
kind of works when it wants to. >> I also I also don't
I'm not real self-confident about being on camera anyway. And
I really >> Oh, I'm sorry. I I'm a I'm an
You look fine, buddy. Okay. You do look a little bit like I would
expect an Emmy fan. >> I don't like being on camera. And
uh also whenever uh >> Listen, I don't go on camera. All
right. You're braver than I am. All right. I'll give you that
one. >> I was shaving my beard and stuff and I messed it
up. Tried to fix it and messed it up again. >> I feel ah
I feel like such an as now,
>> So then I basically shaved it all off >> and not
too happy about that. I'm pretty upset about it. >> But
that's not that's not what this video is. No, it's like a 200
viewer streamer with like 30 200 view video with like 39 subs.
No, it's not a chatter. It's just some dude I think uh I think
R was watching Chud's stream and Chud went to search for videos
on this and pulled this video up and realized that it was funny.
Yeah, I'm just being an I feel bad >> about So, there's
another thing I want to say before I start getting into this
is that I am a Christian and uh >> I'm done. I I can't
I'm not going to bully this guy. I I can't I can't do it, man.
I can't do it. I just feel like an [__] now. Uh,
I'm getting off that video. God damn. Yikes. Yikes.
Okay.
All right. God. What is this one? Did we watch this one? Oh,
this is the Taylor Loren thing, right? This Taylor Loren. I was
going to look at a couple comments from this. So, he's treat
literally treating this as a tehe oopsie. If you don't remember
from the Taylor Loren interview, Dan Clansancy basically said,
"Well, we have a world-class team. We have a world-class approach."
And
and
you kind of can't stop this stuff from happening. You kind of
can't kind of can't stop this stuff from happening.
Uh and you know that's going to pick people off. Who in the hell
is propping up Taylor Loren? She's the absolute
Loren is a hack. She's so soft in this
did they did she stream this interview? I thought she just put
a clip out of it. How is somebody saying she's so soft in this
interview when the one question she asks is, "How are you going
to win back the trust of Twitch people?"
>> Hold on, I have to listen to the question now. >> Now,
what happened yesterday obviously was something that we care
deeply about this environment. You know, we're looking very closely
at everything that happened there >> and I can't she's
a friend of mine and so I want to see how we can support her.
This is just something we have to keep working on. And I think
everyone identifies our tools in terms of trust and safety as
the leaders in the industry about helping creators, but that
means there's always more work to be done cuz that's the world
we live in >> Demi had posted earlier today that I guess
this fan was allowed to cross multiple barriers at TwitchCon.
Why should streamers trust Twitch to keep them safe at TwitchCon?
Cuz I >> was Was this posted somewhere in full? Why would
people say that this is a soft belt interview when he when she
asks about security and then she goes, "Emirew posted that this
person was allowed to get through multiple barriers. Why should
people trust you?" I'm sorry. Just fundamentally that's like
not a softball interview, right? Is this just like a like a GPT
bot posting and saying that this is what's happening? She's so
soft in this interview. The only question I've seen posted is
this one where it is the opposite of a softball interview. Yeah,
it is. It is just the legal approach mad. Yeah, I don't I don't
I don't know. That's why she's doing this interview. I wouldn't
surprise if they rehearsed this. She has no ethics or integrity.
She announced getting this interview before Amir was insulted.
Actually, this is also just wrong and it's the most upvoted.
This is like I have uh I have a lot of people, you know, in my
Discord community who are very emotional like this and they they
they'll just, you know, let their emotions run wild sometimes.
And you have to be very calm when talking to these people sometimes,
okay? They'll just say, "Oh, you said this." And it's like, "No,
I didn't."
But they feel that way, you know? So, you got to you got to handle
them with how they feel. This person feels like Taylor Lorenz
is a hack. They feel like she's so soft in this interview. And
you just have to be like, "Hey, but have you thought about how
you haven't seen the interview yet?" Like, you literally haven't
seen any of the interview. The only interview parts you've seen
have been
have been just this one where she asked a question. He's talking
about security. And then she goes, "Yeah, Emmy, the person who
just got assaulted said she this person had to cross multiple
barriers. How do you win trust
Like like you have to deal with reality here, right?
But people don't want to do that. People really really hate doing
that sometimes. It's sad. Why the mask? Cuz she's freaking out.
She's uh she's super neurotic. Yeah, she's she freaked out during
COVID and and like has uh what is it?
What's the fear of germs? I forget
not agorophobia that's outside
whatever the germ one is. got that that germ that anti- ggererm,
you know.
All right, hold on.
I guess Oh, I guess we're moving to the litter box stuff. I guess
it's that time. Yeah, hold on. This is uh Taylor Taylor says,
"Full interview will be out on my YouTube podcast on Wednesday.
We talked about creator safety, platform changes, freedom of
speech, the currently postponed congressional hearing, women
in streaming, Twitch's role in culture, and a slew of other topics."
So, the interview is not out. Yeah, it's it's just funny knowing
that this is I I I like this portability because it's funny knowing
how like this culture war stuff goes and how people talk on the
internet, right? It's just very funny to me how it's like Taylor
Lorenz is a hack. She's so soft in this interview. This this
was prepared absent like this could have been prepared. This
comment could have been made absent
even watching the clip. Like this person just wanted to get in
there and go Taylor Taylor Lens is bad.
It's very very funny. Uh her color gate video is also awful though.
So ah
germaphobia. It's just germaphobia. All right, dude. The kick
the kick chat is just so like
oh, how do I describe it? It's like having struggles. Okay, the
kick chat's having such struggles right now. It's very unfortunate.